car entre sa douaniers smirnov le match
que personne n'attendait
mais mais quand même là alors attendez
ça doit ni je crois que le hachis doit
être avant le w vrai je sentais qu avec
un nom pareil il y avoir une erreur un
endroit il est il et il est de ce côté
là donc c'est le match que vous
n'attendiez pas mais qui vous arrive
quand même
qui vous arrive quand-même dessus avec
en fait ça doit nice à un jeune hyper
doué dont on parle pas trop mais qui a
un peu dans le dans le délire des geeks
h et compagnie et smirnov c'est un
joueur australien un jeune joueur
australien alors qui est très fort mais
qui rentrera à mon avis jamais dans le
top mondial
alors après peut-être difficile aussi en
océanie d'avoir les compétitions qu'il
faut et l'adversité qu'il faut pour
progresser
en tout cas c'est un joueur très doué
mais mais qui semble être un peu
derrière on va dire ça comme ça on va
suivre ce petit match on va en avoir
comme vous le savez pour 4 heures
quasiment de compétition normalement
smirnov est légèrement favori après les
beaucoup plus âgée je vais regarder leur
différence d'âge
je vais aller checker leur différence
d'âge
je vais vérifier que tout marche au
passage à yamina l échec qui arrive on
va checker leur différence d'âge
à mon avis elle est importante
je pense qu'ils ont moins quatre ans
d'écart parce que ça douane il est
vraiment jeune sadoine il est réellement
jeunes
il est né en décembre 2005 donc il a qui
est là presque 15 ans et smirnov
c'est en tonnes son prénom
il est né en 2001 s et ça ils ont 55 ans
d'écart et en janvier en plus donc il va
avoir 20 ans dans quoi il ya cinq ans
des cartes pour ça je lui dis smyrna
favori légèrement un peu plus fort mais
il a cinq ans de plus en fait sa
carrière est déjà derrière lui smirnov
comme dirait blad il faut déjà arrêter
les échecs malheureusement parce qu'il
est que 2600 à 20 ans et c'est
normalement pas assez pour devenir top
mondial
pas de chance après lé numéro un
australien et il aura une belle une
belle carrière
dans dans sa région du monde dans son
pays un mais mais du coup c'est un peu
léger pour le top mondial après comme je
disais est un joueur très doué mais ce
que t'es pas un peu pénalisé quand tu es
dans un pays comme ça où il n'y a pas
vraiment d'adversité maxime était
combien à 20 ans était peut-être déjà 26
50 mais il faisait ses études et a et
c'est un des rares joueurs qui a fait
une double poussée m'étais peut-être
déjà 26 80 quand même fallu demander
belga deux profs d'échec
ouais alors après je sais pas comment
l'as tu connais pas la situation d échec
en australie mais il va être premier
échiquier de l'équipe d'australie
pendant longtemps il va mais non il veut
il peut il peut avoir une belle carrière
dans le sens où ou dans son pays il est
bien mais bon il est il va être aux
alentours la 150e place mondiale je
pense à son à son meilleur niveau
non maintenant dans un sport comme le
tennis ou quoi ça suffirait à peine pour
être pro aux échecs ça va suffire mais
mais mais voilà ça va pas être un
ça sera pas un crack alors que ça doit
ni sa d'oignies fait partie de ces
joueurs qui peuvent qui peuvent
prétendre à une place de top 20 mondial
un jour à bord après avoir un ils sont
encore jeunes mais il peut il peut
prétendre alors là il peut aussi
prétendre à se recentrer sur sa came
serait pas mal sont ils en train de se
barrer de revenir
on va voir ce que le match donne après
je vous cache pas que la fiche en soit
ça fait pas rêver hein ça fait pas rêver
ça fait pas rêver ça fait pas rêver de
voir ça pendant quatre heures oui là il
est un peu la même moustache est alors
les faveurs du commentateur français se
doit ni et je crois qu'ils jouent contre
sarine au prochain tour donc les deux
vont se faire face is et smirnov ils
auront une chance à oignies normalement
contre sarine il a aucune chance à la
petite moustache à tiens c'est parti ça
me l'a pas mis automatiquement et c'est
déjà une berlinoise ce match qui
commence bien les amis avec la petite
finale de la berlinoise dont je vais
rappeler les enjeux donc majorité
allaient là les droits avec une bonne
structure contre une mauvaise majorité
entre guillemets allèles dame avec une
mauvaise structure et des pions doublé
mais en contrepartie la paire de fou
pour les noirs et surtout un bon
contrôle des cases blanches
donc voila un petit peu les enjeux
stratégiques de cette finale si son
parti dans des berlinoise
on va en bouffer les gars des berlinoise
on pourrait en avoir beaucoup
on va voir ce que ça donne voir ce que
ça donne j'espère qu'on aura des belles
parties si on a la mauvaise affiche plus
les partis un peu relou ça peut être
très très longs mois qui on va se faire
chier
ouais c'est très possible et puis moi en
plus je vais je vais pas je ne vais pas
commenter en mode sportif et toi 200%
passe comme je vous disais à hyères pour
ceux qui ont qui ont peut-être suivi
j'ai des petits problèmes d'ulcères
posés çà l'estomac bon je vais pas
parler des problèmes de santé ou quoi
mais
pour dire qu' il y aura des emballages
ses adieux mvl qui enchaîne s'il ya des
belles parties ou dans des gros matches
mais là pour une affiche comme ça je
vais je vais quand même privilégié le
commentaire plus normal quoi on voit pas
bien les lots et je vais je vais vous
mettre ça comme ça prépare toi qu est
non si si en plus c'est des partis comme
ça tu vois on va pas la nouvelle a fait
un bide est complètement complètement
non il envoie le pion à rapidement ça va
lui permettre d'activer sa tour à 8 ça
peut être un problème dans ces berlinois
ce qu'on a déjà bougé droit je vous
rappelle donc on n'a plus droit de
roquet donc lassé des échecs à la cram
nique mais away du coup à cinq à quatre
c'est pas si con parce qu'on va pouvoir
éventuellement échanger tout le long de
la colonne à pourquoi pas peut-être tour
des trois tours d un pote un plan alors
attendez j'ai pas mis le chrono ça avec
tout le reste automatique sauf le chrono
le chrono faut que je le mette moi même
individuellement alors il doit rester
ouais c'est de mettre un chrono bien la
caméra en plus est mal réglé fous ces
trois il veut changer les fous de
casement bon pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ouais c'est génial c'est
peut-être les gens n'étaient pas là mais
non mais en préambule du match n 6 et 2
c'est le match que personne n'attendait
mais qui va jouer quand même j'ai trouvé
que c'était très drôle
non je me suis trouvé marrant je me suis
je suis marrant je mâche que faire ça
donne a tenté mais kim a joué quand même
ça me fait marrer en fait l'écran est
légèrement floue alors là ça doit être
pour toi par contre parce que c'est pas
c'est pas censé il pas sans savoir de
problèmes de flou
oui ça injuste de comment c'est vrai
battue à d'ailleurs le score est à 0,01
qui est menacée j'ai quatre équipes
rangées 7 la difficulté souvent quand
vous envoyez la majorité comme je le
disais c'est qu'elle peut être bloquée
sur sur les cases blanches
même table que m oiseau sur 1,3 de poker
qui va le mieux représenté la commune
sur un tournant line florian sainte sous
ou sur un tournoi en réel pas su le
bonjour d'ailleurs sinon afghan petit
pull et attend mais smyrne à oui mais
s'il y en a un fils en australie c'est
l'hiver ah oui il est serré c'est
l'hiver il est dans l'hémisphère sud
c'est marrant ça fâche pas ces mares ou
pas mais c'est une info que je lâche
pour lui en fait c'est l'équivalent de
en fait il vient de se taper décembre
janvier il en février quoi presque
complètement fou alors que nous on en
septembre est à pas de chance tu en
février c'est le printemps en australie
ah ouais non hillary l'équivalent en
mars mais à tendance n'est pas le
printemps nous on n'est pas encore nous
on n'est pas encore au noten a si on en
automne merde à mère d'ilan début de
printemps
il est en mars soit il en mars avril et
en mars c'est quoi être m'en fout en
fait en carême en australie c'est demain
mon anniversaire
là c'est un truc de ouf en australie
demain c'est mon anniversaire
assez extraordinaire à les premiers
bourgeons sont en train de fleurir en
fait il est très heureux
smirnov ah oui alors que alors que ça
douane il est comme nous il en septembre
coiffe un fou
et mon frère m'a dit qu'il commençait à
faire chaud alors i am et un frère
australien non mais attends là y'a trop
il ya trop d'infos en même temps comment
françois jack peut avoir un frère
australien j'ai très rarement entendu
des gens qui avaient de la famille en
australie en fait c'est rarissime
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
une information que nous apprenons ah
ouais non mais là là là là il ya des
infos le match est beaucoup plus
intéressant que prévu bon ils essayent
de s'en prendre aux fous peut-être il
veut le prendre pour réussir à pousser
mais le pion en russie sera bien placés
pour bloquer les pions c'est du jeu de
placement 1
je vais pas vous faire rêver avec cette
game mais les blancs sont toujours un
peu mieux les tours sont pas encore lié
le roi viendra en recette si le peul
caillé va sûrement partir vers f 4g six
ou sept f5 ouais c'est bien joué aussi
en f4 est menacé car il y eu deux en
fait au passage ça pouvait être une
possibilité
quel âge les deux 15 ans pour ça doit ni
20 ans pour smirnov ce mini smirnov sa
carrière est derrière lui
comme je vous disais ça et c'est déjà
fini en fait ce sera jamais top mondial
ouais c'est déjà trop tard 6 à 20 ans tu
es pas encore dans le top 150 top 100
mondial c'est vraiment fini che finir tu
n'as plus de carrière
mon cavalier 1 il veut remettre le
cavalier en d3 ou en c2 peut être joué
sur ce fou qui peut être enfermé
qualifié de ça peut être un coup alors
là c'est marrant parce que l'ordinateur
demain donne un grand avantage noir
après fou b4 mais honnêtement à vue
d'oeil comme ça j'aurais pas vu les
avantages noir je comprends que que les
noirs ont réussi à se placer à se mettre
en place que il voit là ils ont ils ont
bien fait une une belle poussée à l'ale
dame mais j'aurais pas vu davantage
noirs ici c'est là un petit les prêtant
un top 10 - ouais ça doit ni peut
prétendre peut prétendre même si je le
rappelle j'ai joué contre lui il ya un
an et demi en pro-chasse ligue et car la
fin de la partie j'avais fait nul et je
m'étais dit j'ai rarement en fait nul
contre un mec aussi nul mais
mais en fait il a beaucoup progressé
mais je sais pas je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de ses joueurs indiens qui
vainquit son d'escaut donc ils font
foule échec 8 9 heures par jour et je
vais en parler avec ba qui en fait ils
plafonnent beaucoup plus tôt que les
autres donc à voir ses joueurs indiens
faut pas non plus les surestimer je
pense qu'on a beaucoup qui vont
plafonner à 26 50 27
on verra et ça lui ferait de gama rue
comment était le match d'abdou beaucoup
de promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues et
c'est intéressant de disons que c'était
intéressant baron saumon pendant 1h20 on
a eu un beau match après pendant entre
1h et 1h30 en fait au moment où son
adversaire a complètement fait tourner
le match dont xiong a fait tourner le
match en sa faveur
on va dire à l'heure de jeu quoi ils
menaient de deux points il est passé à
plus 5 en une demi heure ou plus 6 donc
on a eu on a eu voilà on a eu une heure
vingt 1h30 assez sympa après on a eu
deux heures et demie où on s'est un peu
ennuyé mais en gros en gros voilà par
contre c'est pas mars en australie mais
septembre les saisons sont posées mais
le calendrier le même mais on savait un
docteur jumeaux c'est fantastique en
fait docteur lui pense vraiment qu'on
est très très con quoi c'est
extraordinaire c'est extraordinaire
comment voudrais tu que marche le monde
s'ils n'étaient pas au même mois sera
possible en fait non enfin on est quand
même très con mais quand même pas aussi
con que ça se serait pas possible
juste ça marcherait pas les mecs qui
font des contrats tu écris le 14
septembre d'un mec qui t'appelle wayne
en mai 14 septembre
il se trouve qu en australie c'est le 14
mars
ah oui non quand même quand même car il
ya des limites qua non je suis un tout
con c'est vrai mais avait des trucs
comme ça je comprends quand même ça va
non seulement ils sont en mars mais ils
ont la tête à l'envers est d'ailleurs
ils ont des petits aimants pour tenir
tard zelda sous les chaussures il ya des
petits aimants pour pas tomber wen en
octobre jimmy qui m'a quand même qui m'a
pris pour un gros jambon quand même je
me demande s'il peut pas tenter qu'il ya
des quatre cavaliers avec cinq tours g3
et j'ai six matches bon c'est un peu
culotté
là on comprend quand même que les noirs
sont mieux en maintenant parce que le
cavaliere à six est complètement hors
jeu le tube et trois sous pression le
roi au pire on fait tour prend b3 roigé
si son aura tour j'ai trois échecs
or là ce qui va tenter sûrement sur
tours prend b3 cg quatre tours prend h3g
6 peut-être mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
3g 6 il peut vraiment même et 3g si ça
il va faire tour ici rouaf cette cavale
et des 8,3 et fuite
du coup je vous croise et 8 avec les
noirs bon là tu dois aller il va pas
prendre ce pion à ses super bien joué ça
de jouer pour tour à trois quarts aile
et prend qui a aidé 8 et tout reprendre
un an que le roi ici - les blancs qui
vont un peu la continuer parce qu'ils
ont les pions passer ça normalement
c'est tour h1 je pense le coût pourrait
tour f1 c'est très bien aussi
cavaliers detroit et la tour f 3 donc il
prend un pion il va envoyer g et h méga
cavaliers f5 qui cavalent f7 qui va
arriver
bon là les pions n'iront pas à dallas
les mecs je vous spoil un peu la fin de
la partie mais ils sont bien trop loin
il aurait fallu qu'il soit de trois
cases plus haut sur l'échiquier et c'est
un premier point pour ça doit ni alors
on va voir s'ils avaient comme d'hab
alors il mais il met le match dans
l'autre sens
j'ai envoyé mon âme a annoncé un match
dans ce sens là mais ils ont mis dans
l'autre sens c'est pas grave ça demande
qu à replacer les trucs du bon côté
c'est chose faite donc sa voix ni qui
mène 1.0 après une belle finale
il en va ch monstres et c'est vrai mais
c'est pas facile ils doivent rentrer
dans le match après ils ont le temps 1
ils ont encore trois heures et demie
pour remonter qui est le favori c'est
soit ici alors ses 107 smirnov mais ça
peut ça peut être chaud on est dans les
50 points elo d'écart qui font que ça
peut détendre dépendre des ouvertures ça
peut dépendre du match up fait un tas de
blagues sur sur smirnov et c'est le nom
que porte une vodka russe très connu
est-ce que cramique centralisée revient
à jouer sans le rock je sais pas car
zolder j'ai l'impression qu'il fait
froid chez smirnov aussi là quand même
un gros puis là il a il a un gros pull
mais parfois ça peut être bien de jouer
un endroit où il fait un peu froid
j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
stimulant le froid
bon alors on a eu on a eu quoi que
l'ouverture j'étais en train de lire le
le chat éviter ces genres de réty de
machin qui sont qui ont pu transposer
dans des genres de destins viennent avec
double faire avec ses enquêtes ou de
chaque côté donc il ya un pion plus pour
le moment ces quatre pour les noirs mais
tu vas pas vraiment pouvoir le soutenir
par b5 parce qu'il y aura des oeufs 5
qui vont rodez et dans tous les cas le
cavalier on peut le déstabiliser par 5
sur cavaliers detroit ya b3 qui vient
déstabiliser le socle en c4 et ses
positions qui sont pas simples à jouer
pour les noirs
ils ont masqué les noms des six il est
beau sur le papier mais le problème
c'est qu'ils se bouffent 5 et dames
france et 4 d'ailleurs au sein d'un
procès 4 est une vraie idée là tout de
suite maintenant le cavalier sans vadam
français 4 arrive le quart eli va
repartir vers des 5 et b4 b5 pour
attaquer les dames il commence par tour
d un il a le temps ils peuvent aussi
avoir des cinq comme rupture
intéressante
du coup à 5 il veut il va pas vouloir
reculer le carillon dessin qui veut il
veut empêcher les bécasses b5 dont vous
parlez
si le pion c4 venait à disparaître pour
pas faire briller le fouet le long de la
longue diagonale
bon il fait 1 5 donc il s'en prend aux
cavaliers finalement le coutour autour
des tours a des seins étaient peut-être
superflu mais ouais c'est un coup de
façon que tu aurais plus ou moins eu
envie de jouer donc c'est sarah pas
grande conséquence
le cavalier va sûrement partir à il peut
faire un 8c 7 des 5 pouces et 8,7 des
cinq donc les deux sont possibles et je
pense qu'il veut ramener lieu en d5 et
se faire un truc un peu comme ça mais
les blancs auront la casse des six pour
leurs cavaliers bon il ya un petit
problème d'espacé tout mais c'est pas
forcément gravissime pour les noirs déjà
il n'a pas le fou ces huit bloqué qui
peut qui peut représenter un réel
problème puisque ce serait une pièce de
moins en jeu donc il lui reste les
bonnes pièces après il ya le problème
des espaces et cette caste des 6 un peu
pénible mais bon eh oui les blancs vont
avoir la rupture f4 f5 aussi à terme qui
va arriver
faut que je pète un peu la caméra avec
cette caméra tout en longueur et
vraiment pas pratique donc y met ce
cavalier en d5 finalement j'imagine
cavalier e 4 mais peut-être il veut pas
voir cavaler prendre trois il peut aussi
prendre un sur s'éprend il aurait pu
jouer la halle dames et surprend il
aurait pu jouer les droits suivants dans
quel dans quel sens les noirs remettre
leurs pions et bonsoir à lever cas et on
saura mettre yogourt youssef 5 alors sur
pied en price un qui pourra pour
reprendre du cavalier e 1,8
c'était sûrement l'idée d'aller plutôt 8
quand ces huit c'était sûrement l'idée
d'aller en 1/8 plutôt qu'en ces huit
donc f5 jouer
ben tu prends cavaliers prend aussi sa
fille c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est bien joué ce f5 j'aime bien sûr
fou g5 intermédiaire le truc c'est qu'on
peut bouger la dame et a pu la prise en
passant au coup d'après c'est un des
trucs marrants de la prise en passant
c'est que tu peux pas pas faire deux
élèves à apprendre de la tour je pense
je pensais que j'en attends tu peux pas
tu peux pas faire deux poids
intermédiaire ça m'est arrivé de me
faire avoir une fois de calculs et de
vente avec une prise en passant de venir
à oui ok je commence par ça et je prends
après est en fait tu commencé puis après
tu peux plus prendre
c'est assez drôle ça c'est drôle c'est
drôle vite fait un mais mais ça m'est
déjà arrivé de me faire avoir comme ça
ce qui est désagréable bien évidemment
de et maintenant peut-être on peut
prendre trois maîtres l'autre cavaliers
en d5 parce que là on peut se retrouver
avec une case pour deux pièces après il
peut calculer les f4 aussi mais je crois
que ça mène pas bien loin puisque on ne
réussira pas allé jusqu en f3 j'imagine
qu'il va prendre les cars et laissé 7
qui a aidé 5 à mes cahiers sais tu as
peut-être qu'il prend bessette qui est
des cinq à feu ok c'est chaud mais
prendre le 3e ça donne quand même envie
puisque ce qui a valu huit comme je
disais le carillon dessin qui est
sûrement supérieur aux fous 3 mais le
cavalier 1,8 a pas de rebond et ça c'est
un peu problématique
même si pas grave hein donc fait d'un
match 5
d'accord je vérifie juste que soit
marche bien sur youtube aussi ça
fonctionne
jetez un oeil alors cha du coup à
youtube gens n'écrivent pas sur youtube
justin regarde regarde vite fait j'ai
envie de dire damages 5
et là il ya peut-être une combine ces
cavaliers prend 1,3 puis on prend 2,3 et
fou prend 1,5 que j'ai vu grâce à l'ordi
est sûre pions prend 1,5 y aura dame
français cinq ans mais bon ça c'est pas
très dur ça franchement en partie si je
suis concentré je le vois ça n'allait
pas très dur parce qu'il prend son temps
il a vu et faut prendre 5 c'est sûr
qu'il a vu ça c'est là c'est quand même
assez élémentaire alors attend peut-être
que ce qui était problématique
ceccarelli prend 1,6 à l'évoquer prise
prise prise quand même c'est un pion
bizarre un drap tfou prend 1,5 après ça
a continué à traîner un vrai nom il ya
personne qui regarde et live sur sur
youtube saitama que sa bru c'est normal
aussi un youtube c'est pas du tout fait
pour le live est aussi comme comme il ya
beaucoup d'un d'événements qui sont pas
très intéressants en fait à force c'est
enfin c'est pas forcément une bonne
chose de les mettre en live sur youtube
mais bon le reste pas moins qu'il décide
ça chacun chacun fait comme il veut la
sueur cavalli afca ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'on n'a pas le temps de faire
cavalier dessin qui a rédigé six matches
bon après il y avait sûrement d'autres
coins que carélie des cinq mais juste
pour dire cavaliers f4 menacerait
cavaliers g6 il aurait sûrement joué
fouet fuite quand même il est 2h30 du
matin chez smyrna faut en tenir compte
mais non c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il est
très pénalisé la cie les deux heures
tendres alors est ce qu'il est vraiment
en australie
les produits les ont pas fait jouer
beaucoup plus tôt du coup
youtube c'est grave non non twitch c'est
beaucoup mieux mais pour le live c'est
beaucoup mieux twitch mais après tricher
pour le live youtube c'est plus pour
pour les vo des quais ils échangent tout
au fouet 3
6 je trouve que tenir aof et australe a
appris les australiens mais ce qu'il en
australie je pense pas qu'il ait fait
jouer site quoique ils ont voulu faire
jouer tous les matches à 18 heures mais
c'est vrai que s'il est 2h30 du matin
sur un match qui dure trois heures c'est
vraiment un gros un gros handicap 1
kébé 4 pour la il est pas mal je pense
avec les noirs ce que tu as quand même
le foie justice qui tape qui peut faire
mal à ses pions et a plus vraiment de
rupture je me sens que c'est plutôt les
noirs qui tente quelque chose après il a
peu de temps ça peut être chaud
qui va changer il va tourner à faire
froid pranger cette cavale et b4 ce que
j'ai dit bara conseiller pour les pour
eux l'histoire des échecs moi j'en ai lu
en russe en fait et en anglais
les livres demeure l'olive demeurer pas
mal en anglais et en russe il ya les
livres d'art berbach il veut pas de nul
avec les blancs bon là c'est une partie
où tout peut arriver en fait la finale
doit être fondamentalement plus ou moins
nul mais bon avec si peu de temps sur la
pendule
tout peut t'arriver d'air c'est plutôt
ça doit ni qui est en train de la gagner
puisqu'il a gagné un pion là il va
falloir voir comment ils gèrent le pion
passé en a c'est difficile de donner un
pronostic 1 il protège le pion aux six
parce qu'il veut pas bon il va devoir
sacrifier doré peut-être jouer des cinq
rues 3 doit être un mauvais coup je
pense il doit jouer des cinq accepté à 2
prend 2,6 ou prendre à deux ils poussent
vrai mais maintenant après cavaliers c6
il va la perdre
il va y avoir quelques points 5,3 g 7 et
cavaliers 17 et qu'elle prend 1,5 à
oreille a accueilli 35 avait pattes mais
c'est un piège c'est un piège assez
ridicule puisque finalement maintenant
il a plus de pions il s'est planté quand
il est revenu avec 3 3 il aurait encore
pu prendre là nul s'il est allé chercher
de curage 6
ce que cache pas quelque chose sur
vitrine après mayoral cours de femmes
après la master class de fab à 21h30
en espérant que ça vous plaise
on n'a pas de break d'entrée way après
ça doit ni là il avait il est un mieux
un peu toute la partie je pense mais il
a trop voulu forcer à la finale et il
n'a pas réagi au moment où le pion passé
a été dangereux qu'il fallait juste
aller prendre hfr nul
après pour le live par exemple non mais
pour live tweet tweet chez plus il ya
plus interaction avec la communauté sur
twitter plus moyen de d'interagir et la
communauté sur twitter aussi et plus
être plus les créateurs de contenu que
la communauté youtube qui généralement
fait plus du clic et consommer ce bar
alors que la commune sur twitch mais de
plus avec le via les seube et autres et
après moi je trouve que le fait de
pouvoir revenir en arrière sur un live
c'est assez assez dérangeant parce que
quand tu fais un live tu as envie que
les tous les gens soient sur le sur le
même moment moi je préfère largement
largement twitch en tant que que
créateurs de contenu il ya vraiment
beaucoup plus davantage que sur youtube
après c'est un avis personnel
est-ce que j'ai une idée est d'ailleurs
là la plupart des des streamers on sur
twitch tenais là là du projet assomme
battle écoute je sais pas il y en a pas
deux prévues cette semaine y en a pas
deux prévues la semaine prochaine
voulant faire une contre les vies de la
chaîne gotham chase mais je sais pas
pour le mans il répond plus donc on
verra mais n'ont rien de prévu pour le
moment trois ya les émeutes
et puis je trouve que c'est plus facile
de naviguer d'un contenu à l'autre
youtube en fait ce qui m'agace c'est que
il te met les trucs en recommandations à
à droite en fait t'as les
recommandations etc ça vachement
l'algorithme qui aident l'algorithme est
vraiment beaucoup sur youtube ce qui
fait que les gens qui ont déjà des gros
chêne continue à avoir des gros chêne et
que ceux qui commencent ont du mal à
commencer alors que sur twitter c'est
beaucoup plus facile de découvrir des
nouveaux créateurs de contenu
si je sois plus pris en chasse comme
c'est la même chose ces deux chaînes
différentes briques âge j'en ai une
catcheuse comme ya l'autre cas moi en
fait et gare aux restos pour une seule
base serait chaud pour une somme battle
non j'ai déjà écrit deux fois il m'a
jamais répondu
en fait ce matin j'ai poutre est un mec
avec la référence c'est pas une
réfutation de la pierre que m yogourt 1
c'était juste la variante demi-heure
face un ca réfute pas la pire que mais
c'est une manière agréable de jouer
d'ailleurs là j'aime beaucoup aux 5 avec
l'idée sur pions prends je pense à mes
sur des six il va pas pouvoir reprendre
en 5 ce qui aurait cavaliers prend donc
à voir ce qu'il fait sur des projets
cinq des six alors attendez parce que
s'il peut reprendre le 500 se faire
manger ça va être fantastique d'accord
donc il veut juste jouer d'amd de et te
dire que le pion des six est fort
webb à l'idée de mur tu as bossé c'est
une manière du coup je comprends pas
trop l'idée de ce fait renifler vient
juste de file est un pion alors comme il
avait une bonne position avant un
avantage des espaces etc etc
pardon c'est pas si mauvais il va
pouvoir faire ces 5 et tout mais c'est
un peu dommage de file un pion quand
même la dernière ce battle c'était du
gâchis
je suis bien d'accord
c'était du gros gâchis la bataille
toujours le même problème c est chic et
elle a entre 1500 et 2000 où on se fait
marcher dessus
salma
il fait n'importe quoi smirnov ouais
mais apprécie les 2h30 du matin a
expliqué j'ai l'impression qu'ils jouent
très mal ce match ce qui la fit l'espion
là il se prend h6 il a pas fou prend h6
parce que lecavalier protège il va
prendre ici mais il sait prendre angers
5 il va perdre le pion des six il
reprend j'ai cinq cdu c'est du n'importe
quoi en fait
il a fait g4 ok why not
ces cinq réussi à fixer mais bon il va
se faire déranger par b 6 tôt ou tard et
ça va pas du tout aller
pas du tout aller il a fait 5
il faut qu'ils essaient de garder le
truc envié qui veut échanger essayer de
toucher la casse g5 et il a quand même
un peu de jeu encore j'ai peut-être j'ai
peut-être légèrement exagéré il encore
fous ces 4 kg 500 prend des options
options à vii pour attaquer sur case
blanche
il peut encore il peut encore tenter ça
il peut encore tenter ça c'est à dire
plus ou moins sa seule idée hein je
crois ce type de format est il un bon
entraînement pour les joueurs je dirais
non ninja 30 360 c'est beaucoup trop
long pour les joueurs aussi en fait tu
peux pas faire de la qualité vraiment
sur quatre heures c'est c'est juste trop
long pour pour tout le monde que ce soit
pour les joueurs pour les spectateurs
j'en pense quoi de mon système de nîmes
the way c'est un bon livre après c'est
un peu vieux quoi
c'est un classique c'est pas mal de lire
je sais pas au niveau de l'aspect
entertainment et financier je sais pas
ninja c'est c'est un mystère et la sueur
fou prend 1,4 il se passe quoi il veut
prendre un f set mais il a fait un petit
geste non comme s'il avait raté fou
prend 1,4 parce que surtout au premier
set le problème c'est que d'avoir des
dates des fous des cinq voire même des
juges 3 bougez qui l'a endormi injuste
il est endormi
notre ami smirnov il est endormi lancent
ur hand curieux de savoir s'il en
australie ou pages pas comment avoir
l'info parce qu'il m'a l'air d'être dans
le dur de chez dur là la manière dont il
a joué le temps dont il le temps qu'il a
pris pour reprendre un rêve cette âpre
et c'est laisse à penser que c'est
quelqu'un qui n'avait pas vu la première
qui avait pas vu fou prend 1,4 puis
surtout qu layada match 4 ça ça donne
pas l'impression du tout que ce soit
quelque chose qui marche
après peut-être il a des tours pranger
cette tour f 7 mais c'est trop
spéculatif ça paraît trop spéculatif
pour marcher les gars en tout cas perso
j'y crois pas
qu'est ce tu vas faire des coups comme
moi j'ai un tas déjà tour f 8 1 qui
donne envie taf wef 5 aussi qui est
possible foued 5 perdre encore plus
envie tu bloques un peu cette colonne f
et tu prépares peut-être 4 3 avec des
fous qui arrive en d4 et c'est ce qui
fait non c'est pas pas impressionnant
pour l a pas fait la fourchette avec la
tour web ainsi le faisait en fait il
récupère un peu de matériel mais il
était bien derrière matériellement du
coup ils décident de foot un peu le
bordel en faisant tout reprend f7 et en
jouant pour la taxe sur le roi mediapad
attaque mais il fait il fait beaucoup
d'erreurs smirnov damage 6 maintenant
propose les échanges des dames c'est
fini il ya ces pièces net de moi en plus
j'ai ici prend besset tuera de suite
tourbe et 8,4 c'était ce que je veux ce
dont je vous parlais maintenant lieu
peut-être fou des fous des quatre échecs
et fou prend ses cinq faut faire gaffe à
ne pas se prendre une dame en c3 mais
c'est une idée qui va rôder qui donne
encore une claque une calloc'h encore
mais touré fuite c'est le coup logique
floue afsset
il évite tous les échanges par là il
faut un peu de sang-froid côté à côté ça
doit ni mais ça doit aller au bout et on
prend un essai est déjà qui doit suffire
mais t'as pas forcément envie de rentrer
du matos mais mal autant attention un
peu sous pression dame g7 la tourache 5
hayatou h5 quand même et oui rend la
dame
il a pas vu il a raté tous rage 5 c'est
sûr sinon il aurait fait tout point f7
quoique il veut peut-être tourage cinq
tours fc tours h7 tour h7
du coup il a fait dame prend il va faire
tout rage 5 maintenant ce qui n'est pas
idiot tourage cette tour h7 et h4 il va
envoyer les pions
3 il peut pas faux m6 il va prendre
prendre d'alger 6
on va faire h5 ici 17 possibles tour dès
8h cinglant dame f5 3g c'est toi le truc
c'est qu'il ya trop de pièces
il a rendu la dame volontairement je
pensais qu'il avait pas vu mais il a
fait ça volontairement et les blancs qui
n'ont pas réussi à vraiment organisé
data qu'il faudrait qu'ils réussissent à
mettre une double attaque justement
mais là il ya fouet fuite le roi qui va
repartir il a quand même les deux pions
passé lié à les fonds envoyés les pions
la sert à rien de mettre trop d'échecs
de toute façon le roi il va se cacher
c'est complètement inutile
il faut envoyer les pions
c'est la seule chance est là maintenant
il a un peu traîné
le truc c'est que s'il fait autour des 3
il va menacer de tout reprendre alors
tour des 3 et ce qu'il peut y avoir un
père pète il met l'autre tour en d3 3 je
suis dames 8 dames 4,3 g 8 dames 8 x
fuite dame g63 je suis dame f7 bien joué
dames 1 8 le retour d'un me cale il va
réussir à faire perpète face à doni qui
devait pas mon avis partir de l'autre
côté avec son roi en réalité pour aller
se cacher proche de ses pions il avait
l'occasion un moment donné je pense de
partir vers des 8 et il l'a pas fait
il n'y avait pas d'un f 7 à peut-être
dès 2007 mais je pense qu'il n'a jamais
rien rater il n'y a jamais vraiment eu
de double attaque ou quoi c'est serré
pour l'instant et il retourne dans cette
dans cette position d'un récit qui
transpose peut-être d'une anglaise réty
qui n'ont ils commencent par une
anglaise et transpose en fait non ce
truc là je ne sais pas comment comment
comment ça s'appelle en fait mais c'est
un truc que je joue aussi avec les noirs
c'est un genre hey tu m'envoies des
messages après robin side robbins aille
plutôt c'est pas le match le plus à cela
la fiche la plus passionnante donc
t'inquiète pas je jette quand même un
oeil sur mes messages que j'ai reçus par
l'organisation de contour noir
bon ils revendent dans cette position
qui avait pas eu l'air d'être
fantastique pour les noirs ce avait
semblé sympa quand même pour les blancs
va récupérer le pion c4 il a quand même
les quatre pions là qu'ils sont bien
avancés il à la paire de fou ouais ça
doit ni qui n'est pas tjrs et qui m'a
pas l'air d'être très au point là dessus
5 et qui va jouer alors être des saints
qui va tout ouvrir sa pas l'air d'aller
pour les noirs les pièces sont trop
crier quand on échange tout truc si on
échange tout c'est que le fou il arrive
en dessin qui l'attaquent bessette la
tour bien place en d1 là il peut juste
reprendre en c4 récupérer le matériel
prend 6,6 d'abord apprendre c4 après il
a récupéré le matériel et il a beaucoup
de jeu
après peut-être que c'est un vrai fil à
l'habitude de se coucher tard on n'en
sait rien
peut-être ça le dérange pas de jouer la
nuit j'ai eu l'impression qu'ils
jouaient de manière un peu trop
optimiste dans la partie précédente mais
ça lui a réussi
peut-être que c'est sa manière de jouer
aussi un temps g8 d'accord là le coup un
peu réflexe est de faire droit à chacun
de ses pas forcément bon et ça lui
l'ombre de quelle île ami laurent h 2
bon c'est les rois charroi h2 c'est
pareil c'est juste pour dire quand il ya
une tour qui arrive en face de votre roi
et qui a plus trop de trafic devant la
la dame elle doit aller en russie ce
normalement elle va être bien placé à
l'édifice il a chassé et elle s'en prend
à pas mal de choses notamment les pièces
les pions ses six f 5
on va voir si c'est ce qu'ils jouent
ça semble être le coup logique 1 après
pas forcément le meilleur non plus un
mais il y va c'était le coup logique en
tout cas calé des cinq par la pollution
est vraiment compliqué est-ce que
prendre f5 et une option
d'alger si c'était possible pour les
noirs mais peut-être y gagner le pion
aux 7 du coup avec le pion à eux après
passé et qui ont de plus il a fait
cavalier des 5
il protège le set en fait qui était
aussi attaqué d'ailleurs et surprise en
f5
il veut sûrement faire 6 mais bon ces
pions plus sain pour les blancs après
c'est jamais simple
du coup on a une heure trente de cinq
minutes une heure de trois minutes et
trente minutes de bullet c'est ça à
l'ombre de cave et ambühl est celle kahn
qui est favori c'est ça doit ni
bizarrement je pensais que smirnov est
un bon jour de bullet par maintenant de
cavalli qui va arriver à eux quatre g5
attaquer les cases blanches autour du
roi fou des six c'est un petit coup
intermédiaire ça mange pas de pain ouais
c'est un peu court au long de 2 km
peut-être trois heures 3 heures 2 heures
une heure ce serait mieux pour être bien
sûr
attention de placement d'un cavalier ou
trois ici il a raté ça doit ni j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya quand même pas mal
d'erreurs dans ce match pour le moment
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas mal de
petites scories tactique ce que la f5
comprend il avait clairement pas vu le
cavalier 3
ouais
alors après il peut y avoir des choses
mais clairement il avait pas vus ils ne
paraissent pas très affûté les deux
c'est vrai qu'on avait vécu des matchs
on a vécu un beau match quand même
avant-hier avec abdou sato rohff contre
zoug où ça c'est envoyé quand même du
très lourd là on sent que le niveau de
jeu est quand même bien plus faible le
policier était compliqué mais là il ya
des cavaliers c2 qui rebondissent en d4
en os 3 ça fait très peur ben là là là
là honnêtement l'acquis épreuves 1 ça
touche la dame et puis on prend des 5 et
sur dame prend des cinq à tour prend b2
donc ils protègent b2 alors après les
deux joueurs sont plus forts que moi un
soyons bien clairs mais par rapport au
niveau de jeu qu'on a pu voir dans
d'autres matches ça me paraît bien plus
faible que ce qu'on a vu de la part des
niayes sarine le abdou cette europe
contre occasion que je pense que les
deux joueurs étaient plus forts il ya eu
çà rana aussi qui m'a paru au dessus on
l'avait pas fait en direct mais j'évite
de faire garder pour me tenir au courant
et ça m'avait l'air d'être bien au
dessus de ça
là ça m'a l'air d'être un peu faible
après est ce qu'ils sont dans un mauvais
jour aujourd'hui
est ce qu'ils se tirent mutuellement
vers le bas alors dames 6 attention
parce qu'après dame prend des cinq dames
prend des 5 fu prend des cinq ça refera
une fourchette donc il faut être un peu
attentif il fait frais fuite
alors ça va lui permettre de mettre la
tour angers 7 c'est bien joué ils se
libèrent la casse pour la tour pour
doubler ouais trois mille chaises comme
et après voilà les deux sont pas dans un
grand dans un grand match ça arrive
parfois qu'il ya un joueur qui joue un
peu moins bien que ça entraîne l'autre
aussi à un peu moins bien joué
de ce convoi du contenu a quand même
dans toutes les parties des grosses
erreurs tactiques à chaque fois pour le
moment ce qui avait été à mon avis un
peu moins le cas dans les matches
précédents
après peut-être qu'ils jouent des types
de position aussi plus exigeantes
je pense qu'il ya la culture prend b2
ici c'est le coup je regarderai temps
prend b2 dames c'est un prix zeddam
prend b2 puisque tu réattaque j'ai deux
en fait
et si prends tu prends et tu couvres les
cases noires ce qui fait plaisir c'est
ce qui la joue et on prend b2 jussie
quand tu marques un temps d'arrêt c'est
pour jouer genre de variantes et ils
échangeraient et il prend b2 et du coup
la dame est super bien placé sur cette
diagonale
elle contrôle vraiment tout ce qu'il
faut je pense lisez ça peut être de
faire f4f 3 et devenir tous des sols est
d'autres désolidariser par non pour
récupérer au 5 allée gagné la petite
finale
ça doit ni qui est très mal autant
pousser cette dame c3 j'aime bien il
veut revenir en g3 peut-être et faire
f4f 3 alors est ce que fout c'est 5 et
un coup ici à aimer fou g7 s'est bien
joué parce qu'il veut pas laisser de
heil a pas fou prend 1,5 à fou prend 1,5
elle est pas si facile que ça à finir
peut-être fouache si si si avec qui des
fois f4 d'arâches deux fois çi ça me
donnerait envie je vais regarder alors
d'içi un problème n'y a pas de frais
lors didonne dame f3 comme seul coup
mais il a joué tous âges 6 d'ailleurs
d'un f3 seul coup mais ça prend dans la
finale tu as pas du tout envie auquel
haye adam est un fief 4
ça c'est ma tondeuse assez basique mais
smirnov qui prend les devants
ça doit ni qui a l'air un peu agacé à
l'écran mais c'est vrai qu'ils ne
montrent pas un gros niveau de jeu et le
joueur indien
allez petit fou prend ses six dans la
berlinoise à foisches 6 après c'était
dur de pareilles matt matros yogourt 1
c'est pas parce que tu le vois que quand
tu joues c'est dur la pollution était
déjà désespérée c'est pas là qu'il a
fait l'erreur c'était le f5 qui était
vraiment mauvais après deux là ont
découlé tous les problèmes donc la
petite anti berlinoise
il peut ramener le cavalier en c4 pour
attaquer le pion aux 5 fu g4 du coup il
vient se débarrasser d'un des deux
cavaliers iran la paire de fous où ils
avaient faux at this de coups avant
françois jacq way s'est testé la belle
idée en fait foi le 6 mai je l'avais pas
vue directement non plus une fois que tu
l'as vu en fait foi à 6tu comprend tout
de suite que ça gagne mais faut le temps
que ça arrive en fait mon là le pion et
attaquer donc il faut le défendre
cavalli aussi c'était une autre option
ça joue ça joue pas mal côté smirnov
quand même il ya eu les petites fautes
mais après dur au démarrage là il a
l'impression qu'ils sont quand même
qu'il a un peu resserré le jeu et ce qui
peut vouloir jouer avec le nom et ce
qu'il veut faire f4 qui comprend qu'il
est prend des six fou prend un f4 ouais
c'est ça exactement
allez salonique est pas content et ça
sent le bon coup ça le problème pour
expliquer c'est qu'après pris çà çà çà
tu aimerais bien faire grand roque pour
défendre le pion meillassoux g5 à bien
peut-être oui mesdames prend b2 rock est
peut-être faut rentrer là dedans
peut-être qu'il faut rentrer là dedans
il prend de la dame du coup et ce pion
b2 était en prise et c'est vrai que
c'était un peu gênant mais là c'est un
peu mieux pour les blancs c'est fou
contre cavaliers position assez ouverte
c'est pas grand chose mais c'est plus
agréable à jouer
bref 5 km la tour en vain essayé de
faire une expansion prendre l'espace
allait droit
ce lien https léger favori du match
après moi comme je lé il ya un an et
demi quand je rencontre sadoine il
m'avait pas du tout impressionné je sais
pas comment je n'ai pas battu en fait
mais à mais il a énormément progressé en
partie longue il a fait d'énormes
résultat il a fait trois nuls contre
cariat kiné compte des gros joueurs et
moi il m'a il m'avait pas du tout du
tout impressionné ça m'avait eu l'air de
te profil de joueur qui a beaucoup
travaillé connaissent très bien la
théorie mais qui sont pas forcément
super en compréhension du cou qui sont
plus dangereux en partie longue
généralement après à cet âge là ça
progresse très vite quand même réduit à
4 il va vouloir éventuellement mettre le
pion à 5 installés sont fous joue un peu
le pion des cinqs agréable à jouer pour
les blancs meilleure structure ouais
c'est ça tu travailles deux ans sans
aller à l'école tu peux tu peux vraiment
envie de progresser 1
alors je sais pas si lui il est
déscolarisé mais quasiment tous les tous
les joueurs indiens à bon niveau sont
sont déscolarisés c'est vrai que
forcément ça aide
donc il a fait le a5 pour faire cet
échange le petit avantage blancs réside
dans la structure de pions il ya des 5
et bessette qui sont isolées mais dur à
attaquer parce qu'ils sont sur des
colonnes fermé on voit que la tour 17
fait un bon job là est menacée tout
point réussie si on prend six tours avec
huit matchs c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
rage 6 et tour f5
il s'en prend deux fois aux pions qui va
avancer non y'a pas y'a pas de problème
pour les noirs là ça va ça va échanger
vais avoir des quatre tours b 5 ça va
les changer
il se passe rien les amis
alors tour des saints qui va échanger ok
il veut mettre la pression quand même un
qui avait quatre c'est bien joué surtout
reprend décati le cavalier e 2 donc la
tour va partir alors il va faire pour
des huit tours 17
je pense bien rouages de pour avoir tout
reprend des 4 3 il veut cavaliers prend
des trois tours prend des quatre qui est
prend des 2 tours 17
essayer de gagner le pion b jouer sur le
pion pas à cc contre le cavalier c'est
un peu qu'on veuille juifs à long terme
d'être déscolarisés comme stowe comme ça
non écoute horizon qui prend b4
bah du coup ils savent qu'ils vont être
joueur d'échecs quoi mais vu que c'est
plutôt une bonne situation en inde ça
leur convient très bien
non c'est pas la norme à haut niveau
mais chez les jeunes indiens c'est la
norme et il va quand même la jouer avec
les blancs parce qu'il veut essayer de
ramener son roi et de pousser il est
peut-être un mois je trouve plus facile
à jouer pour les blancs en fait parce
que la tour en bessin qui est supérieur
à la tour ces six là j'imagine que tu
vas faire j'ai quatre avec l'idée
d'avoir le pion qui pas de bloquer f5 et
de vouloir jouer virtuellement avec un
pion de plus parce que les trois pions
avance pas ici alors qui va faire ou f3
il va se laisser échangés ouais c'est ça
douaniers avec les noirs qui a proposé
nu le type cloud 54
c'est une bonne situation genre d'échec
en inde
ça doit ni qui part alors ça c'est
complètement interdite ça c'est
complètement interdite alors il donne
l'impression de quelqu'un qui est où la
porte a sonné où il ya eu un problème
il n'empêche que il faut le faire entre
les parties c'est terrible c'est
terrible après c'est toujours pareil je
suis je suis sûr à 1000% qu'il ait rien
allez faire de mauvais il a dû avoir la
porte qui sonnait ou un problème
d'ailleurs la proposition nul il a
accepté
il se trouve que tu peux pas le faire
donc
bon après on a bien vu la position
c'était pas une position à problèmes
sans adversaire a tout de suite proposé
nu l'hyper fair play mais bon
normalement on doit le faire entre les
parties les carreaux le fais tout le
temps oui mais c'est pas parce qu'ils
car ou le fait qu'il faut le faire un
kir on retourne dans cette variante avec
avec les noirs où il n'est pas très bien
depuis depuis tout à l'heure mais oui où
finalement il retourne les parties donc
on peut tout à fait comprendre qu'il est
qu'il est l' envie de retourner dans une
position qui semble mieux lui convenir
d'ailleurs il ya complètement eu un
changement je sais pas lequel a dévié en
premier je peux aller jeter un oeil ces
quatre hot kebede 2 je vais aller jeter
un oeil à qui a dévié en premier c'était
celle-là
adam tu dis prenant ces quatre il a
quand même des vies avec les noirs et
prenez 6e coup ils prenaient en c4 il a
dévié hilare ok c'est vrai qu'il était à
chaque fois mal avec les noirs et même
si ça lui réussit c'est plutôt pas mal
il a décidé de dévier ça c'est pas mal
ce plan à 5 carolis et six cavaliers ab4
ce que tu fais à 5 tu veux a4 a3 tu
provoques a4 et du coup tu te gagne la
case b4 et c'est assez cool là il peut y
avoir des cavaliers à deux cavaliers ces
trois parfois c'est un truc que vous
m'avez déjà vue jouer en partie sa
forcément à prête à surfer de cavaliers
à deux tours à 1
et quand tu rebondis ans et trois dames
e1 était pas sûr d'avoir quelque chose
or là il se trouve que l'ordi donne
cavalli p4 et que ça va mais c'est un
truc quoi il le fait qui peut qui peut
parfois ne pas du tout marché mais qui
est très thématique ça se voit à présent
les cavaliers qui rentre avec le fouet
f5 qui contrôle les cases blanches well
as a fait très mal en fait en vrai ça
fait très très mal à l'écart et lise c3
qui a et b 4 il l'a trouvé il a vu le
cavaly b4 ici très bien joué de la part
de smyrna fin il n'y a pas de bonnes
découvertes avec le cavalier d2 ce cas
seule caste cb1 mais à qui prend bien et
le fou contrôler la case aussi à wayne
on met lass et kata pour ça doit ni sa
ses katas immédiate du cui l'objet
d'échangés mais qui menacent fou des
trois d'ailleurs aussi sur dame saint
lyé cavaliers deux échecs
c'est même juste difficile d'empêcher
fou des trois peut-être des
affaires/droit h un fou des trois tours
j'ai un peut-être c'est déjà ton seul
coup pour pour rester en vie
trois chambres il le joue fou détroit
quand même
il a encore envie mais par un tour de
passe-passe 1 il est encore en vie par
un tour de passe passe et ça va pas être
facile de le rester
il reste combien de temps il reste
encore une demi-heure dans ce dans cette
première partie on va dire
fo prend ses quatre prises ces quatre
peut-être et ses 5 pour s'ouvrir le fou
ou c5 direct plutôt pro a pendant ces 4
s'est pas fait encore c'est pas fini
mais il s'en tire bien quand même ça
doit ni je trouve maintenant réellement
en dessous un spin off qui a eu un début
de match difficile peut être expliqué
par par un début de match tardif pour
lui un comme on l'a dit si je vous
d'australie ce qui est très probable il
est quand même 2h30 3h du mat
peut-être une mise en route plus
difficile et puis maintenant qu'il est
en route
maintenant qu'il est bien réveillé ça
envoie
la c5 sur pied on prend un peu hard et
qu'avait lieu de attaque ici attaque là
on peut vraiment séparé du foot cases
noires dans ses positions là dans le
sens où les blancs n'ont plus de fous de
cases noires donc ils vont pas pouvoir
mener des attaques de maths ça semble
très bien se passer pour le joueur
australien
je pense qu'il peut faire mal parce que
le début de match il était vraiment
plutôt al'avantage de sa doit ni qui n'a
pas vraiment convertis et s'ils se
retrouvent à -2 dans un truc où il
commence à se faire marcher dessus petit
à petit ça ça peut ça peut honnêtement
ça peut honnêtement être vraiment
inquiétant pour lui là il prend b4 il
prend ici
il attaque la tour croissance ou de
cadres elle peut pas envoyer des
attaques de matt dillon qui peut
théoriquement mais si on perd le foot
cazin il va pas pouvoir faire de
batteries pour à l'attaqué en g7 donc
prendre la qualit en un c'est pas
dangereux on va jusqu'à nier du matériel
l'après doit hésiter à faire des 3 et
tours 17
parce que la tour du coup elle va
revenir ici et sa menace stratégique c e
5 e 4 cyl pions arrivant au caté suivant
f5
on aura une mégastructure sur casse
blanche avec le fou de cases noires ça
va faire très très mal ça je sais pas si
vous le voyez bien que e 5 e de 5 à 5,4
et une grosse menace stratégique
d'ailleurs sur cinq il faut jouer au
quatri siens si les noirs jouent aux 4 f
5 je pense à abandon jours ait eu quatre
sans trop réfléchir perso même si c'est
dégueulasse mais ça me ferait trop peur
de me prendre ça avec le jeu parfait la
synergie foot cases noires pions sur
case blanche
ouais je suis repassé environ 21h30 ce
sera la master class de fab en espérant
qu'ils aient un peu de monde
je suis un peu inquiet parce que déjà
d'habitude quand je fais les premières
parties a pas grand monde
donc je suis un petit peu inquiet mais
bon on verra après je peux pas faire
autrement j'ai pas le choix donc il a
fait 4
le choix que ce 4 x 6 maintenant il doit
falloir se résoudre à sacrifier en c3 a
essayé de récupérer le pion des thèmes
de la master class ses attaques sur h7
donc pris ces trois prises ces trois
dames france et trois dames des quatre
ans j'aurais quand même sacrifié après
il a le choix entre mâles et pire mais
là la dame qui arrivant des quatre il ya
f5 qui va arriver quand même si on prend
1,4 quand même des deux dames f1 dam des
cas j'imagine c'est horrible ce pion en
d2 est beaucoup trop fort il est soutenu
par le fou le cavalier qui contrôle les
cases importante autour regarder toutes
les cases qui sont contrôlés dans le
camp dans le camp blanc il veut juste
sur 17 tours des 8 ou f54 damage pas
juste 3g set je pense protège le fouet
le gars d'ici là c'est un massacre
il doit calculer dame point f2 aussi
mais bon moi j'ai c'est tranquille il
reste 20 secondes assad oignies c'est
terrible 5 comme prévu elle peut même
prendre de la tour il peut faire re 4 il
peut tout faire
ça donne quasiment vides abandonnées il
ya tout reprendre ya pions prend tout
est jouable prendre la tour il va mettre
la torah afc est maintenant augmenter la
pression et le jour où la tour par en
plus ya ça qui peut être en l'air et
c'est un abandon saïss mis en oeuvre qui
commence à enclencher la deuxième et la
troisième vitesse
c'est maintenant que le match peut se
terminer
terminer là s'il enchaîne deux victoires
ce qui est très possible vu l'ascendant
qu'il a il passe à +4 et à mon avis ça
doit nine ne reverra pas le jour
allez mon indien reprend tony saitama
extrême il m'a l'air d'être moins fort
tout simplement les gars il m'a l'air
d'être moins fort c'est ce qu'on avait
prévu un après mais bon puis c'est un
match qui peut théoriquement y avoir une
surprise plus trop drax adouani qui joue
avec avec l'équipe d'arménie ça pouvait
ça pouvait donner un espoir mais non
il est dans le dur lorelei racaille
prend bessette
c'est une honte c'est honteux de ratés
qui prend bessette ça c'est honteux
il a juste oublié qu'ils avaient pris en
17 ans là il est vraiment vraiment
inexistant il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ce soir
d'ailleurs il se prend la tête et oui
puisque là si c'est vrai que plus moins
trois là tu commences à être malin de
son point de vue tuco tu commence à
rentrer dans le territoire dangereux
terrible vais y réfléchir ce qui va
joueur qui prend des six pions prend les
fous c3s qui va faire cavalier à 5 dame
prend b2 grand roque le petit rock
pardon les deux sont jouables faudra
quatre pieds dame france et 2 mais pour
le moment c'est cadeau un cahier renan
c'est une énorme erreur oui là je vous
simple il faut 3 il est vite sur calais
décati frafu prend des 4 allez faut
tenter rock et f5 encore ou des cinq
lors didonne quasi égales ce qui est
étonnant malgré le pion de plus donc
c'est peut-être pas si grave même si je
comprends pas pourquoi
probablement parce que ce clonage est
difficile à tuer en fait elle a
peut-être eu un peu de réussite et que
c'est pas été si grave c'est théorique
ce pas si cons
voilà il va faire 4 4 cavaliers f5
ouais c 4 c'est pas mal joué il met ses
pions sur blanc qui bloque
honnêtement je comprends pas pourquoi
leur didonne égal ce qu'elle est un vrai
plus en plus à ces cols compte à rebours
c'est le temps qui reste dans la section
5 + 1 pour vendre le score est de 4 2
dans cette dans cette section et reste
encore un peu plus de vingt minutes à
jouer donc il va rester 3 peut pas
rester trois parties encore il peut
rester trois parties encore dans cette
sélection après encore une heure de
trois plus un an quand une demi-heure 2
1 + 1 le truc qui est bien pour les
noirs en fait c'est que le cavalier
arrive plus vite en d4 que le cavalier
blanc f5 en d5 part il peut arriver avec
5 par an dès 5 ans et smirnov qui s'est
lavé qui se barrent les règles on
s'emballe heck
ouais ces deux joueurs sont un peu plus
forts que moi ray il va faire h55 qui
m'a dit mais c'est qui ayant aussi s'est
bien passé défendant le plomb g7
est-ce que grand roque est complètement
fou ici ouais ça a l'air d'être assez
fou
ok tour g1 il veut s'en prendre il veut
commencer à s'en prendre à g7 mais c'est
bien blindé la lord digby kleinhans ont
déjà beaucoup mieux après prise prise ça
va être sont une idée je sais pas de
quoi avec quoi il veut prendre et j'ai
cinq cas les f-5 dames c'est cette
qu'ils changent d'avis dit grand requin
blanc mais enfin c'est vrai que c'est
pas si simple avec les blancs tu vois
pas comment profiter de ta majorité et
finalement les noirs ont plus de jeux
avec leurs pièces
c'est bizarre parce que fout g4 c'est
pareil c'est tellement mauvais
ça paraît fou
j'ai cinq affaires qui a valu à 5
ça paraît fou que l'ordinateur donne
mieux pour les noirs ici quand même
quand même un pion de moins
on va voir je pense que c'est quand même
les blancs qui vont mettre la pression
je n'arrive pas du tout à voir pourquoi
les noirs seraient mieux on va voir mon
cas et des quatre candidats déjà gagnant
pour les blancs après h4 il disait qu'il
fallait jouer quoi il va il faille faire
flasher 5
admettons dame ok j'ai trois dames c'est
cet ait interdit grand roque
il veut faire lui grand roque est
attaquée colonne des as we f3 genre pour
faire grande pour les noirs et les
blancs réussissent pas à mettre le roi
sur une bonne case
ok je peux comprendre qu'ils aient des
quatre coups d 4d et maintenant l'ordi
adorent h4 est donc oui c'était vraiment
un truc précis qui donne l avantage au
noir est évidemment j'étais sûr qu
humainement les blancs allaient prendre
le dessus surtout à ce niveau là après
d'eni au niveau des gars quand même vais
aller tout tu dis trouve tout de toute
façon
il fait h4 est en fait sur g h i veut
jouer d'alger cette étape à grand roque
l'ats pascal adam mal plaçant des huit
way et du coup si tu perds le pion g
après il ya tout qui avancent donc ça va
faire très mal
ouais c'est très compliqué antoine qui
donne qui donne l'impression d'être
fatigué mais c'est vrai je suis
quasiment sûr qu'il en australie donc la
lidc sur alger fg dame g5 d'avoir dame
prend 2,4 après faut encore calculé roi
des 2 1 ce genre de choses peuvent être
très dangereuses parce que le roi est au
centre est l'atout arrivons enfin il n'y
a pas d'échec il est pas rentrer
là-dedans il a fait grand roque alors
surprise ici doit y avoir f4 il y aura
pas de 1.4 à cause de tours 1
il est d'origine russe smyrna fabrique
comme son nom indique je crois que ses
parents qui sont allés vivre en
australie
ses parents sont russes détroit avec
l'idée est de faire dame un roi des deux
dames prend à deux mais y'aura roi ou 3
et le roi sera intouchable on veut trois
essais le roi noir qui est très faible 1
8 en réalité parce que lecavalier f5 et
surpuissant il contrôle beaucoup de
cases autour du roi et des qui va
connecter avec la dame il va faire mal
donc ça semble être une victoire qui se
dessine pour pour smirnov qui peut
prendre trois points d'avancé ici kg
cette 3e set car il y avait cinq alors
l'idée de faire ça c'est d'éviter les
petits rock parce que le roi n'avait
toujours pas bougé donc on est parvenu
tout à fait la même position et
d'ailleurs si on faisait trois fois la
même position se serait pas nul
parce que dans une position il avait la
possibilité de faire le rock et dans
l'autre non donc c'est pas tout à fait 1
3 fois la même position c'est une petite
finesse de la règle
je profite de ce moment là pour vous
l'apprendre
je suis sûr que y'a pas tourner qui
était au courant en fait c'est pas trois
fois la même position puisque dans une
position il y avait la possibilité de
roquet est alignée plus dans l'autre
donc ça a changé la position
c'est une règle assez logique au final
un don qu'il a pris çà il prend le roi
qui va sûrement partir ans est certain
c'est la meilleure case d'alger 3 puis
on prend h4 c'est logique et maintenant
ils adam g7 qui gagne elle n'a pas fait
la fée calais prend h4 qui gagne quand
même un sûrement ce que la finale il a
quoi il a il a deux pions plus wayne
donc il est large
c'est un adversaire qui va les prendre à
deux ep 3 alors à temps il peut faire
froid ces deux dames à deux rois ces
trois dames à st croix b2 bien joué mais
le rang b 2 qui sera pas touchable y la
qualité puis en plus ça gagne ça fait 3
points et ça commence à faire cher pour
pour ça doit ni la qui est dominé dans
le jeu vraiment il fait des gaffes il
est pas impressionnant
l'écart qui enfle la différence qui
semble se faire la côte est côté smirnov
bon alors il change complètement son
fusil d'épaulé avec les blancs il a
arrêté ses saisons de la dri qui reste
treize minutes ouais donc notre chrono
mais tu est pas tout à fait juste
on est trente secondes en avance donc il
y aura encore deux parties celle là et
est une autre normalement il faut
absolument pour ça doit ni tournée
allait faire tourner à 2.6 personnel est
la suivante tourne à 5 qui pourrait déjà
rizaï le match mais il sera obligé de
jouer encore deux heures pour être bien
sûr j'ai envie de jouer même allumé la
lumière
la gérante eut accueilli celle ci je
crois tu laisses le fouet ou quatre mais
tu laisses le foot tu peux pas tu peux
pas te permettre de repères d'un tempo
avec tu donnes la paire de fou pour
avoir gagné le contrôle du centre je
vais allumer la lumière j'arrive donc
d'apprendre à me prendre et si si si si
tu prends f3 yaris et une en l'air il y
avait le x nanterre
il y avait le foie n'en ont l'air fou tu
essaies de jouer
pour s'éviter à peut-être marqué ses six
maintenant et c'est de mettre la tour
ici ou cavaliers à 6 comme ça t'évite
peut-être les cas et b5 et yeux caê b4
quand même et tour ses huit cavaliers
ses 5 et d 3 ok ça se prend il va mettre
une tour ans et 8
ça joue sajou tranquille pour ces huit
jouer fuhe de ça à prendre c'est un vrai
tank est tombé 4 où ils tous
renseignements
je pensais qu'ils allaient commencer par
kébé 4 pour menaces et qu'elle prend à
deux en fait mais bon façon qui a et b 4
à damas ah oui bien jouer damon hill
très bien joué ça et oui puisqu'il ya
plus de fous de cases noires il veut il
veut il veut il veut faire mal sur
casino d'enghien fort enlever le
cavalier faire f si ces cavaliers eu
cinq créer un mur faso face aux
cavaliers adverse
c'est obligatoire
il n'a pas le choix il doit absolument
faire ça alors ils peuvent être le
cavalier autre parent ou quoi mais tu
vas devoir faire cette petite
construction pour
pour bloquer pour bloquer le foie
adverse
y a pas de choix il a fêté et b4 il peut
le faire plus tard mais je veux dire par
là que c'est une idée qui va qui va
devoir employer
coelho fit des deux joueurs ils sont aux
alentours de 2600 les deux après ça doit
n'y a peut-être un peu moins mais après
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'ils jouent pas
et ça et qu'il est en pleine progression
carélie g4
quatre champions prend il veut cavaliers
prend il empêchera la prise en h2 et du
coup sûr f6 on n'a plus la case 5
donc il prend quand même prise et
cavaliers céderait donc d'accord il en
là les blancs sont clairement mis la
paire de fou c'est fou de cas se fout de
cases noires qui est super bien placé
les noirs qui ont pas réussi à maintenir
leur centre envie qui se retrouve avec
un pion et cela arrive a un peu joué sur
l'activité mais on voit que les pièces
blanches sont bien bien mieux placé qui
fait des 4 d'accord il veut profiter que
lecavalier ne peut pas prendre parce qu
adam proche de morlaàs il ya plein de
possibilités il ya h3 ya eu prend des
katja fou prend des 4 prend des 4 semble
déjà suffire pour avoir un avantage
apprends les 4 semble largement suffire
pour obtenir un avantage
il commence par h3 il s des trois
intermédiaires
les mendoises erpion prend puis on prend
dame prend ça va son adversaire le jour
il réfléchit à quoi la c1 9
[Musique]
le fou est enfermé il ne prend pas tout
de suite d'accord vous êtes enfermés ne
le prend pas tout de suite aimé le fou
angers 4
il fait ça ici il prend maintenant il va
peut-être revenir avec le cavalier en b
4 pour menacer cavaliers detroit et
préparer tour ces deux comme ça fait
qu'ils avaient quatre des quatre tours
ces deux dames b5
ok c'est chaud je préfère les blancs
quand même les pièces or elles sont pas
très bien coordonnées fous ces trois
vagues géantes cavalli prend à deux pour
commencer c'est complètement fou à il a
pas vu il a il a encore fait un
mouvement de tête puisque le cavaly il
va rebondir vias et en d3 oui non mais
c'est terrible ça comme faute fous ces
trois ratés qu'elle prend à deux c'est
terrible moi je proposais des cats qui
empêchait les détroits et qui prouve
protéger le pion à 2 après la position
reste tendu parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeu pour pour les blancs mais c'était
clairement pas volontaire alors il fait
il fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
d'erreurs
un terme à six d'accord il rend le pion
mais c'est vrai que la position était
trop difficile à jouer
il va faire f 6 ramener le roi
il va essayer de faire nul smirnov bien
géré il avait une position pas si simple
il est devant dans le match et puis avec
les blancs il met quand même beaucoup de
pression donc il peut être content de
faire nul et d'essayer de tourner à plus
4 en gagnant la prochaine ce qui sera un
gros avantage pour le roi des qataris et
6 le petit piège qui avait laissé 6 1
mais va voir [ __ ] en f3 cavaliers aux
cinq épreuves trois maintenant
ah oui c'est il s'est complètement auto
magouiller
ça doit ni ah oui ça fait très très mal
ça parce que le pion à ge va filer
tellement vite le cavaliere 3 et super
bien placé contre les cases noires ah
oui non mais là c'est terrible
voilà c'est terrible le pion à shief il
ça sert à rien en plus des cinq des six
sur un roi aussi c'est très mal joué
c'est vraiment très mal joué des 4 c'est
le pire contre jeu je trouve
bayrou 8 3 17 bien joué le pion va être
juste arrêté en plus il va contrôler la
casse des six le fou avoir du mal à
venir se sacrifier le roi il est pas
dans le carré du pion du roi c'est katia
h 4 h 3 h 2 h 1 dames
voilà il va juste poussé h puis j'ai il
a vraiment juste du mal à venir se
sacrifier si c'est fou des six il va
faire froid 17 le pouvoir bouger il va
faire j'ai 5 g 4g 3g 2 il est il est
beaucoup beaucoup plus rapide mais s'il
va faire trois décès dont s'il veut et
h32 il a il a vraiment juste du mal à
sacrifier
et ils abandonnent et ouais ça fait il a
très mal joué la finale il a
complètement mis la fourchette
c'est fou enfin là il fait vraiment des
erreurs tactiques grossière sadoine il
est pas dans le match un peu nul n'est
pas du tout dans le match
c'est vrai que l'écart 4 points
complètement dominé ça risque de faire 5
assez rapidement ça risque de faire
rapidement 5 points d'écart annonça
douaniers on voit qu'il est en plus il
n'est pas en confiance il fait il fait
beaucoup d'erreurs simple si tu tournes
a déjà tourné à -4 c'est dur on espérait
pour lui qu'ils tournent à - 2 - 3 est
ce que c'est le pire match qu'on voit ou
pas mais je pense que peut-être un c'est
peut-être le moins beau match jusqu'ici
même si c'était pas gagné d'avancé
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez les
bitumes x on voit pas les pièces parce
qu'il met un truc où ils veulent que les
noms soient noirs alors cette chasse
comme river est ce que c'est le pire
match de ce pitch junior depuis le début
peut-être un c'est pas le pierre
françois et saint qui a eu des matches
assez pourri mais c'est peut-être pas le
pire
il fait partie des pires nice avec les
deux trois premiers étaient vraiment
quand même assez absolument pour y aussi
un
mais voilà toujours pareil 1-6 6-2 dans
notre format de 7 le match très fine il
en fait on va se taper leurs 45 de jeu
en plus qui sert à rien c'est vraiment
c'est le problème en fait c'est que tu
as vraiment les deux tiers du match qui
qui sont une perte de temps
sèche pour tout le monde alors que le
match devrait s'arrêter maintenant
finalement on a eu à subir daf était
plus fort ah oui non non il ya encore on
est con et co 5 +18 vig presse arrivé
une fois un retournement de situation
des situations pareilles mais dans le
match et menaient louis ou haendel avec
complètement raté son début de match ils
étaient remontés
donc il peut y avoir un retournement de
situation et j'imagine que sur 100
matches et on aura peut-être que si on
jouait pas trois heures mais qu'on joue
et 45 heures d'affilée il y aura encore
d'autres résultats
voilà une bonne position avec les noirs
il le sent là qui sait c'est l'occasion
de remonter
j'avais pas vu les val-d'or deal et
l'ordi donne moins de 30 je pensais que
c'était de cet acabit là les noirs qui
ont tous le jeu allèles dames les blancs
qui ont rejoint rien allez droit
ouais c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi tenir
série de l'art qui léchaient les deux
protagonistes à là c'est intéressant sur
dame france et 3 puis on prend ces
trois-là et b2 est enfermé à l'ac milan
l'a fait vraiment très mal
la ja x 3 qui menace également lassés
par tea party cadeau qu'a partie donnait
donc ça doit ni va rester un peu dans le
match mais ça il faut aussi tenir compte
c'est vrai que si il est 3h30 du matin
chez smirnov ça peut il peut peut-être
ouais c'est vrai que c'est un facteur
qui peut créer un retournement de
situation
voilà c'est fini ses pièces de moins
il est obligé de faire dame france et 3
en plus même pas besoin de faire le x 3
qui arrive fond c'est que la dame avait
une case pour partir et qui aurait floué
à 3 même pas
après vu la forme de sa doit ni ne la
jouera un peu je ferai ça et d4 j'aurais
fait exactement ça vu la forme de sa
doit ni moi je leur a un peu joué quand
même j'aurais pris 11,5 et j'en rêvais
exactement pareil que smirnov
oui les postes peut être fatale à
smirnov suis d'accord avec toi à cyril
c'est vrai qu'il peut il peut il peut
espérer sur le décalage horaire ça
douaniers
qui sera qui pourra lui être fatal au
projet 4e f 3 meilleurs appuis on prend
1,5
c'est vrai que ça peut lui être fatal je
suis d'accord avec vous les gars ça peut
être fatal aux joueurs australiens
pourrait subir la loi
de la fatigue il vend un piège le foot
pro f 3 tours si ce moratoire f7 mais
fou prend des airs c'est pour montrer
ton prince est soit c'est sa petite idée
non mais bon tu peux faire ça ça ça aide
bref cette va rien se passer un si la
tour par ailleurs à roye 17 et si la
tour vient là je sais pas mais il a
juste pas de menace avec les blancs avec
les noirs et les blancs en fait je
reviens juste pas de menace mais c'est
là qu'on voit qu'il n'est pas en
confiance
même là il a du mal à gagner après bon
s'il ya de nouveau des énormes des
énormes erreurs comme là on a fait
smirnov dans cette partie peut revenir
il peut revenir dans le match tout le
malheur qu'on lui souhaite un
c'est tout le mal qu'on lui souhaite
vous prendrez travailler voire tous
réussissent
autour h7 c'est la même chose
tous gagnants vraiment ou gagne je pense
fois six tours fc doit gagner à tours fc
tourcoing fc 3 1er sept tours à faire
mais encore j'ai quatre cavaliers pros
eux 5
même ça ça doit gagner honnêtement tout
gagner ici
absolument tout gagne lorsqu'il choisit
un mea
quel point est il n'y a juste pas de
cours en fait il ya tour 17 ah oui donc
il ya encore un petit problème mais bon
menaces émanant d'un mais tourache huit
tours fc est fou prend 1,4 cette fois ci
c'est fini
le piège là est il content là ça doit ni
l'afu prend 1,4 ça termine bien la
partie calme à faire je sais même pas ce
qui peut faire là dessus mais bon il
s'est quand même fou tu m'as l'otan sa
douaniers avec flash 5 bien joué ici
elle est abandonnée
ouais bon il recolle un peu il est ce un
poil de suspense il laisse un poil de
suspense dans le match mais je vous
repassez la partie comme d'habitude je
vais mettre la pub et on va se retrouver
dans cinq petites minutes moi j'en
profitais pour aller manger une petite
banane ça pas me faire de mal et on se
retrouve dans cinq petites minutes
alors attendez up les petites pub je
vais repasser la dernière partie et on
va se retrouver à de suite les gars
à
je suis de retour tu passais pas
c'est grand chose
donc
donc ça va reprendre il ya 6 3 il ya 6 3
on va voir ce que donne la deuxième
partie du match 1 qu'est ce qu'ils
mangent
j'ai pas réussi à voir ce qu'ils
mangeaient pas ils ont changé leur
caméra de sens terrible je précise bien
que ce n'était pas du même côté
ok
une gamme qui fait que lorie atouts qui
a changé de sens oui ok ils ont tout
changé de sens en fait j'ai compris ils
ont tout changé de sens c'est pas des
haricots on sépare ainsi peut-être des
barres de haricots cas uc4 c'est ici et
c'est tf3 ça va repartir
peut-être qu'il a réussi à corriger le
tir
on va voir en quoi il retourne pas dans
le des princes et qu'at-il vous damas
quatre cette fois ci les joues et je
crois qu'elle bd de la dernière fois
c'était une variante théorique c'est sûr
on n'arrive pas à voir ce qu'il a mangé
et j'ai pas mis le chronomètre attendez
je remette le chronomètre à mon chrono
mais trier ou mon chrono m il est là du
coup ça va être
je m 59 minutes on va remettre le chrono
et on va repartir pour 59 minutes de 3 +
alors attendez est ce qu'on peut voir ce
qui manquait ce qui est sévère non ça
c'est une barre c'est une barre de
céréales
c'est un plastique autour c'est une
barre de céréales
il se donne des forces
donc il prend des cinq points des cinq
reprises je vois pas pourquoi les blancs
auquel et blanc où une majorité centrale
mais je vois pas pourquoi il aurait
vraiment un avantage on va te mettre un
fond g4 une tour en des 8 et on va s'en
prendre à ton pions sur fief 5 il ya eu
4 1 donc la dame serait pas enfermés
mais peut-être fou g4 pour attaquer la
et attaquer là il prendre pions tassé
des coûts a parfois que je rate ça parce
que ça me fait peur du coup des fois ils
ne viennent pas à toi je sais pas il a
tourné à [ __ ] en f2 est faux à six
fours g7 et qui prend des quatre dames
prend des quatre fois ci s'il va bouger
mais c'est toujours peur de les prendre
ses pions qui apprend des quatre dames
prend des 4 b 4 four b2 tout ça me fait
très peur après je dois avoir tort mais
ça m'effraie fouet f4 bien joué
d'ailleurs
5 x 6
il va mettre la tour en d1 après ça vexe
un pion de plus un
après ça un pion de plus
c'est un bon piont de plus
c'est vrai que finalement c'est un but
en tenions bon piont de plus et si cela
doit me réussit pas utiliser ces cases
noires il s'est peut-être compliqué la
ville à ce que finalement ce pion ce fou
quand il va le prendre il est noir pour
reprendre du pillon ils seront assez
contents ils auront la tour 1 8 qui
visera le pion et je sais pas ce plan
des cats il me paraît mieux qu'en
recettes
il permet de mon sens qui permet de
faire des choses donc il fait autour des
1 maintenant l'autre va faire flouer 5
vient jouer dame c1 et il va falloir
calculer les cavaliers c5
d'accord il fait dame ces cinq dames g5
à intéressant parce que maintenant sur
damev s'il n'y a pas d'âme et fuite
la défense parce que il a mis le fouet
la la j'ai généralement le font ici
c'est la dame en âge cissé ya la défense
damas fuite
mais là il oblige peut-être dames 7 et
ça lui permet de reprendre cette hausse
est récupérée peut-être des quatre îles
var perdre 2 mai tour d'un leroy va
rester faible quand même et ça lui parle
is an dall ce qui va prendre prendre
prendre prendre prendre prendrait tour d
un j'imagine et mettre la pression sur
la case des 8
alors là il peut peut-être faire tour
prend b2 et tourbains pourrait changer
la tour
ça peut être une idée ça qui fait tout
rue 8 pour dire je vous demande ça
marchait trop enlevée de tomber un se
passe sur un bon là l'avantagé c'est que
la tour en temps 17 à grandes pandémies
ce cavalier lapierre pièce dont il faut
le replacer là c'est forcément les noirs
qui sont même jusqu'au pire de toute
façon tu rendras un pion fou aux six
cavaliers des cinq ça va être le plan
est très logique
match intéressant aujourd'hui
honnêtement je trouve pas trop hein mais
après chacun ses goûts 1
on suit les parties en tout cas au
maximum on comprend des choses mais je
trouve que le niveau de jeu est assez
piètre par rapport à ce qu'on a pu voir
dans d'autres matches qu'elle avoue
prend un tour 17 peut-être devra faire
attention puisque a peut-être tour deux
tours 8 essais les noirs qui contre
attaque sur carte blanche aux siens ils
peuvent être contre dangereux en fait
les noirs l'a repris du pillon et l'idée
ses tours ses huit ici mais le problème
c'est que tu as du mal à te libérer de
ce truc là que surtout on sait si à tour
des huit matches sur france 5 fu à fouet
cinq toiles je vois pas comment tu
réussi à te dépêtrer du truc voiture
devra faire b6 ou à 6,3 et fuite mais le
fauve à venir en aide si tu vas être
bloquée d'accord une idée c'est de faire
et fils 3ème set peut-être f5
mais là tu es tellement faible sur noir
wife sept tours 7
il va essayer d'être fou 17 pouces et si
ça fout 17 la tour f 6 il peut pas il a
dû commettre une faute
smirnov lorsqu'il a repris du poids
parce que du coup il se fait vite c'est
alors que s'ils prenaient du fou il
réussissait à chasser la tour
bon après il al'avantage du temps tout
de même ses adversaires qui jouent vite
et qui a que des coups faciles
voilà il a très mal joué la smirnoff le
pion prendrait 5 et l'autre à donner le
pion toujours son pion de plus mais on
le sent pas du tout ce qu'ils ont de
plus le roi est très bien placé il va
mettre le foin e4 je penserai c'est
assez bien je dormis le fond le 4 mai
maintenant des quatre sur fou prend des
cats il doit avoir tour des cinq mètres
laurent f7 et là ça fait nul
ah non il ya encore roi ici 3e 5 qui
protège tour moi je trouve qu'il ya
quand même mal joué aspire 9 a poussé 6
pouces et six gagnés la pièce il l'a
raté il a raté fous ces six pressé dur
avec peu de temps comme ça de voir les
opportunités était en semi près move
avec avec une seconde sur la sur la
pendule c'est la galère il peut faire
tourner france et ces trois points f4
way to reprend ses sets ça doit gagner à
mes atouts prend bien d'ailleurs
enfin gagner non non ça gagner pas mais
fou prend bien fou prend bien gagner
bien évidemment assez terrible cette
erreur de sa doit ni qui était remontée
qui file qui file à tout en un récit
tout repenser à roye point f casque en
fait envoyé le pion oui mais bon il y
aurait toujours eu ro abc ses assistants
ça faisait juste nul face ils voient
l'écart se creuse dans une partie où je
trouve que smirnov a pas super bien joué
et finalement c'est l'indien qui lui
donne la tour en a trop de gaffes un
côté indien
c'est pas la première
on arrache 5 il le fait maintenant parce
que le problème de h5 c'est que ça donne
la casse g5 mais vu que lecavalier est
venu en e2 il a beaucoup plus de mal à
atterrir dessus l écart qui se creuse
meiway sur gaffe 1 la 2 ça doit ni mais
j'ai trouvé le cepr en d5 assez mal
joueurs la part de smirnoff qui devait
avoir l'idée de se libérer mais kim et
qui marchait pas du tout mais ça ne
marchait pas du tout ça continue à jouer
qu'ils envoient le plus long qu'à
attention à ne pas jouer j'ai trois
héros qui prend f3 mais ça ça ne fait
jamais trop peur avec les blancs ce que
je lis tu vas faire grand roque un jour
tu réussiras quand même affaire f4
l'avez peut-être des fous b6 qui rôdent
façon fou b6 est plus ou moins forcé et
le cavaly va peut-être repartir vers f4
ouais c'était pas forcer non plus mais
c'est joli
alors qu'elle sait cette c'est culotté
parce qu'il est il a plus de cases de
sortie c'est très culotté c'est
extrêmement culotté en fait ça peut
fonctionner mais ça peut fonctionner
mais c'est quand même spécial parce que
même s'ils gagnent des six en fait il
reste enfermé
car il offre 4 problème c'est qu'ils
avaient faux at 6 peut-être même y
aurait eu fouet trois quarts lycées set
ça vraiment la tête d'un coup j'aurais
pas regarder ça c'est terrible
j'ai quatre rouges et quatre rouges et
quatre tours des f1 gk piégée 4 je pense
qu'il doit prendre est de toute façon
prend il va mettre la tour en f1 ou en
ga en f1 je pense contrôle f3 essayer un
jour 2 de s'ouvrir la colonne maintenant
ce cas valiant cessé tard il prend ici
prise prise y accueille prend ses 4
juste bêtement le truc c'est que même
après qu'il prend des six comprend des
six lecavalier toujours enfermés en fait
c'est ça qui est terrible
ouais mais alors comme il est venu là la
tour est pas protégé s'il était venu en
g7 sûr qu'il ya des saints qui aurait eu
plus on prend et tout reprend mais là du
coup sûr s'éprend dessin cafu prend b8
attendait et sur ces produits n'a pas
fait rage et s'attirer un problème c'est
un mystère pour moi parce que ça lui
aurait permis de faire ça et ça ok je
comprends rien la partie là
ouais mais fou et 5 il avait officié ce
nom bref si juste sur fouet 5 c'est moi
qui hallucine ci avait rien bon du coup
il ya égalité matérielle et petit
avantage noir quand même la paire de fou
donc il va échanger il va essayer de
monter le roi il va essayer de monter
droit
toi je suis toutefois je suis tjrs et
des six peut-être auxquels ces cinq ans
est aussi logique il va vouloir monter
droit ouais le joueur australien qui a
le dessus parce que ça et qu'il a quand
même des sacrés poubelle mais les
cavaliers ces sept là c'était fou les
dents revenir ans et 7 avec son fou il
n'a pas trop le choix
parce que le problème c'est que si tu
protèges avec le car il y aura foule 4
tab et l'iphone 4 fois je donne je
comprends rien la partie en vrai il
devait y avoir un autre problème sur
foot c'est set mais j'ai pas compris
après que le redis a confirmé ce que je
pensais de base j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya beaucoup de l'iaaf en fait
j'ai besoin qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
de gaffes dans ce match c'est pour ça
que ça doit ni peut la gagner 1 il est
tellement tard chez smirnov
il m'a vraiment l'air d'avoir fait
absolument n'importe quoi dans cette
partie des votants t3f 5 kg 7,3 f4 fort
c'est fou c'est cette le petit piège
je pense pas qu'ils le prennent à faire
cavaler c5 je pense fou j'ai un roi des
rois issifou d63 ici une fois h2
peut-être le retour ça mais pourquoi tu
en es fou de couleurs opposées
c'est le mauvais mais pourquoi tu fais
ça tu peux pas juste faire b 4 à 4 des
quatre rois ici à quatre baies 5 ha ça
va pas faire nul tout de suite non j'ai
tort il va repartir avec le roi en vain
ils menacent roi f2 il va mettre le fou
en b6 gt3 fou b6 fois où j'ai deux fous
ces 5
c'est la même et les noirs les noirs
passent jamais mais c'est incroyable
avec les noirs d'être rentrer là dedans
non mais là c'est pas une question de
bien jouer aux échecs ou pas en fait
c'est juste complètement fou de rentrer
là dedans est fou c'est 5
mais tu sais très bien qu'avec peu de
temps à la pendule et maintenant épreuve
fait par wave 2 est fou ces trois mois
il peut défendre comme ça non la
technique c'est de défendre avec le fou
sur cette aile là avec le roi sur
l'autre aile le foot doit défendre les
pions et à mesa incroyable ce qu'il a
raté sa douanes et non mais là c'est là
c'est quand même embêtant parce que
c'est pas une erreur tactique ou quoi
non c'est pas trop pourquoi ça continue
à jouer c'est dans l'intérêt de personne
là quand ils fassent plus dans un
terrier de smirnoff mais c'est pas
smirnov qui voulait pas jouer c'est
juste incroyable en fait c'est étonnant
c'est réellement étonnant c'est
réellement très étonnant pl je suis j'ai
pas les mots en fait parce que échanger
pour entrer dans la foux de couloir
opposé c'est le dernier truc que tu as
envie de faire ses jeux je sais pas je
ne sais pas si pour vous ça paraît
évident aussi ou pas mais c'est vraiment
le dernier truc à faire spécial c'est
très spécial
c'est très étonnant d'avoir joué ça
comme ça mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est quand même enfin je
suis je suis étonné en fait là encore je
suis encore sous le choc les amis les
deux joueurs je l'a vraiment mal leur
match jab son qui se tirent tous les
deux vers le bas et qui se font
mutuellement mal joué en fait parce que
ça correspond pas vraiment alors à leur
niveau normal ça ne correspond pas
vraiment à leur niveau normal c'est
super étonnant
c'est vraiment étonnant
bah oui ouais je suis sous le choc parce
que parce que ça joue mal là il doit
calculer ce qui peut prendre et faire f
ouais mais là il prend des trois tu peux
pas tu ne peux pas donc à 17 600 prend
pions des 4
c'est la débandade arraf sépare on peut
pas vraiment appeler ça une des mondes
tada 1
le match est juste bizarre en fait par
rapport aux tournées dans des phases
qualificatives
on est on est dans les quarts de finale
berly non on est dans les huitièmes de
finale par dont on est en huitièmes de
finale après encore quatre quarts de
finale demi finale et une finale on n'en
voit pas le bout ils picolent smirnov
bah écoute et apparemment il est 4h du
mat là au moment où il joue ça fait déjà
deux heures de match pour lui donc
franchement c c'est compréhensible ce
qui fait je j'aurais du mal à jouer à 4
heures du mat aussi donc je peux
comprendre sa fatigue mais là ce que
vient de faire ça doit ni c'est juste
très étrange d'être entré dans la peau
de couleur reposer vraiment sa fille ce
week-end où on va jouer les
prolongations au nom ça va durer encore
là ce week-end c'est l'approché slicks
attend encore pour deux trois semaines
ça finit le 8 octobre
c'est terrible c'est terrible cette
compétition c'est d'une longueur c'est
long les matches selon la compétition
est longue dans le camp tout est long
niveau de jeu assez décevant et deux
semaines montrent qu'elle soit mais on a
déjà fait la moitié de la compet là
c'est bien tu vends bien le truc assez
difficile de bien de vendre à iso propre
il normal on aura des beaux matches à
partir des quarts donc les prochains
mais après
c'est pas facile de bien le vendre c'est
pas se passent pas très pas très bien
fait c'est pas très bien foutu
il faut enfermer le fou enfermer les cas
et c4 qui rata quant aux trois quand
même aidé 2 donc qui sauve la faire mais
qui va permettre de le ressortir
il faut en faire comme marvel fitness
c'est terrible le pleutre ils ont de
l'avenir ses joueurs smirnov non pas au
plus haut niveau ça doit ni peut-être à
prévoir a qui jouent mieux que dans ce
match mais bon il m'a vu il m'a l'air de
passer complètement à côté
ils font fermer comme marvel fille c'est
terrible l'humour de ce tchat
alors cette finale faut faire gaffe il
ya toujours b5 qui menaçait food et 3 je
vous prends f1 pour ces quatre des cinq
tours prend 1,4 sa tournée doit faire
bref si ce 3e set
fort d un je pense qu'il va prendre b4 à
prendre b4 et en prend cinq pardon et
maintenant il va prendre des 6es tour 17
non je devine aucun coup en fait je sais
pas si c'est bon signe ou parents en
vrai parce que maintenant il va réussir
à faire droit aux six f5 et tour c'est 8
il va tout blindés encore qu'il ya
peut-être g5 avait pris la paf et
j'aurais peut-être pu jouer avec g5
ouais c'est pas mal ce comment je vous
fait il ya un afflux en défense pour
être guerrier qui repart vers là-bas
retour h5 qui va arriver
allez là il défend et mais là il est
quand même sur le fil du rasoir
après l' avantage c'est que c'est dur a
pronostiqué comme match parce que tu
sens comme il ya beaucoup d'erreurs ça
doit ni pourrait vraiment revenir quoi
voilà c'est parce quand même très mal
pour smirnov qui réussit à récupérer ça
il va essayer d'aller se venger sur f4
va prendre hc3 f6 ya quatre des cinq qui
rôde il est remonté un peu autant si
défense à la la il joue bien avec les
noirs même s'il va probablement la
perdre parce qu'il est mal depuis
longtemps mais il joue bien dans le sens
où il réussit à mettre une vraie défense
en place et c'était pas gagné
disons qu'il pousse y pousse son
adversaire à réussir la tacc il aurait
peut-être pu prendre h4 mais c'est dur
il a tellement pas de temps fort avant
kipré move de partout mais là il a
tellement pas de temps avec les noirs
depuis il va faire froid sait s'il va
essayer d'aller le maté amis appathurai
4 rémy à tour prend des six il ya il
doit y avoir une découverte qui fait mal
roy c'est cet ami l'a encore cavaliers
ces cinq ans ya tout racisme at il
défend tout
il est tentaculaire il est tentaculaire
avec les dents rayent menace encore maté
maintenant entourage quatre ans une
incroyable
il est incroyable il va bouffer le pion
ah non il pouvait pas y avait tout rage
sept îles à incroyable avec les noirs
aux la défense qui vient de te mettre
il a été impressionnant il a été
impressionnant et maintenant il va
essayer de la gagner
oui là il a vraiment été fort en vrai en
vrai autant c'était pas terrible jusque
là au tampon g63 prend ya mat
il a été impressionnant faudrait pas
qu'ils à perdre quand même et ça va
faire un nul mais il a été très
impressionnant il a été très
impressionnant en défense
je sais pas comment il a réussi à tenir
ça pendant combien de coups il a réussi
à paga fait à wayne on l'a vraiment là
vraiment incroyable ce qu'il a réussi
ah ouais
franchement il a élevé le débat smirnov
après ça doit ni il n'est pas exempt de
tout reproche
parce que normalement tu dois gagner ce
genre de position et quand même faut
souligner la grosse grosse grosse grosse
défense de du joueur du joueur russe pas
de joueur australien du coût d'origine
russe qui a quand même envoyé un bon 40
coups sans café avec son roi et son
cavalier et qui a réussi à arrêter le
pion h avec des idées de maths des
machins il a vraiment été ouf
bon là il prend quand même de gros
risques avec son roi voilà il refait
n'importe quoi c'est la deuxième fois
qu'il fait ça et smirnov
après une grosse partie qui rate
complètement son ouverture
parce que là ça va ça va complètement
joué devant son roi et pas devant le roi
des noirs alors il peut tenter de la
sauver
c'est pas la question mais ça va pas du
tout en soit ça ne va pas du tout mais
quelle partie de ouf quand même il a
réussi à se consolider
bon ça s'est passé pas aussi grave que
la dernière fois où il avait carrément
perdu rapidement
ah ouais mais maintenant il se fait
ouvrir ici aussi
non ça va pas dire at vraiment sa game
ans
froid qui tombe pas tout dit en me
lasser
c'est ça la teuf vous souligné que c'est
grâce à ce format hyper long qu'on a eu
la chance d'avoir cette partie non mais
là je suis pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
vraiment je suis pas sûr que smirnov
gagne ceux qui viennent d'arriver je
rappelle juste qu'il est 4h20 du matin
chez lui qu'il est qu'ils jouent depuis
2h30 du matin j'ai l'impression que
juste qu'il a des sautes de
concentration ce qui me j'ai exactement
le même problème quand je fais mais mais
mais stream nocturne un don qu'il est
vraiment pénalisé par par l'horaire ce
sera tout à son honneur s'il gagne le
match mais c'est vrai que ces sautes de
concentration c'est souvent dû au
sommeil ou à la fatigue
avec une telle défense puisse paraître
des petites fantaisies et c'est
d'enfermer le fou à 4 ce qui est une
idée
wayne on ne peut pas être au top de sa
forme a fait ci fait si tu te lèves à 4
si tu te lèves pour jouer à 4 heures du
mat tu peux te régler peut-être ludwig
mais le truc c'est que fait moi je
pourrais être en forme de 4h30 à 5h30 si
j'en avais le besoin le truc c'est pas
ça le truc c'est d'être en forme de deux
heures du matin à 5h30 ça c'est
impossible à moins de changer
radicalement son style de vie pendant
quelques semaines mais tu vas pas faire
ça pour un tournoi lambda quoi mais là
non là tu peux pas fait de quatre heures
à 5 heures tu pourrais un peu décalée de
lever à 3h30 de trois jours d'affilée ça
peut aller mais là c'est pas possible il
peut pas défendre ses chances à 100%
vous faudrait qu'il joue la carte
ritaline mais bon t'as pas forcément
envie de te pourrir la santé pour un
speech junior quoi
en tout cas là on voit qu'il peut pas il
peut pas être au top de sa forme là
c'est pas possible
voilà sa pièce de plus la position doit
être gagnante pour les noirs il ya deux
options acheter bien placé il ya le roi
qui est mal il ya beaucoup de jeu mais
bon on va voir s'il réussit à encore à
nous placer une défense un smirnov
on va voir
bon ça réfléchit ça dernier qu'il trouve
pas de gain pour le moment il ya bien
rien il faut monde maintenir la pression
m le pion à ge de sap à la radio prend
une fois il va reprendre enfin peut-être
le petit piège sur fuji inquiets
étrangers on peut pas reprendre de la
tour c'est bien jouer le roi g7 dans les
blancs ou pas de cours le fou sert à
rien cavalier peut pas bouger la tour
non plus il ya tour g1 au prochain ou
fou j'ai un
qu'est-ce hiver en géant il veut tout
prendre peut-être partie complètement
ratée par les blancs façon s'ils se
qualifier au prochain tour smirnov
contre un adversaire un peu je crois
qu'il joue conte sarine
il aura aucune chance papa à cause de
son niveau de jeu intrinsèque mais à
cause de l'horaire même pas la peine
qu'ils viennent
c'est même pas la peine qu'ils viennent
ces blancs et aux hanches et peut
devenir guéant pour les blancs faut y
arriver là tu as quand même le plonger
qui arrive il va arriver en g3 puis
angers 2
ok veut dame prochain mg5 c'était le
piège adversaire qui a fait le seul truc
pour pouvoir la perte se mettre très mal
autant voyager 2 qui va arriver là il va
se faire sûrement mater avec du dam des
deux dames à deux tours b2 qui arrivait
et qui mate et bombes la position était
catastrophique 1 à les systèmes de
londres ouais ok le match qui
al'avantage d'être indécis tout de même
reconnaissons ça à ce match
reconnaissons ça à ce match qui est très
indécis ça doit ni qui pourrait vraiment
être devant s'il avait moins gaffé
25 il est évidemment ces jouets dame
prend b2 et ont fermé la torah et
maintenant j'ai cinq fois ces théories
crois qu'elle est bien cette vente pour
les noirs tu vas jouer sur les cases tu
vas tu vas t'en as il s'en prend pas aux
fouilles tu verrais j'attends prend nos
fous tu vas t'en prendre aux pions tu
vas jouer là-dessus là-dessus là dessus
ça je crois que c'est très bien pour les
noirs
ça doit être cool fou g7 peut-être même
pour reprendre
cavalli j'ai eu 7 aussi qui est jouable
pour venir un peu tous protégés
protéger le fou protéger le cavalier il
doit pouvoir prend ici un ce qu'avec le
foie est ce qu'avec le cavalier
peut-être avec le fou d'ailleurs prise
reprendrez bien viser sa violemment ça a
l'air bien pour les noirs cette position
on va voir s'il réussit à en faire
quelque chose donc prise prise il va
mettre une pièce en d3
la route des karellis toujours évident
pour toi web c'est l'habitude un temps
je vois une belle qu'à kazan détroit
j'ai envie d'en être un cavalier dessus
et salua kewin 31 dans le tchat
non après smirnov qui fait une une belle
performance en termes de de résistance
et mentale etc
ça doit ni qu'ils aient pas chaud
aujourd'hui à moustiques hausse parce
que franchement c'est pas du grand semis
en a faim c'est vraiment pas du grand
smirnov en face c'est du smirnov
prenable une position avec blizzard un
pion qui sont avancés par tous elle est
pas mal ça la syrie là je veux pas me
faire l'avocat du diable mais il est
tard c'est normal que smirnov jouons mal
joli bien trouver celle la salle est
très très bien trouvé elle est très très
très bien trouvée c'est la meilleure du
jour pour cyril of à salah elle était
pas mal
elle était originale elle tait parce
qu'on a on a eu beaucoup qui n'était pas
très original et cela l'a quand même
gagne quand même la médaille parce
qu'elle a l'originalité avec à elle été
allaités belle salle à elle était très
belle elle était très belle bien
au-dessus de tout ce qu'on a eu de tout
ce qu'on a eue avant série love qui
place la barre assez haut quand même
il place la barre très haut saleh était
vraiment bien
exposition à un certain niveau il garé
garde ce chantage aux foules à tour sort
pas du coup les noirs ont les pions très
avancés ici je pense qu'à faire wife's
est bêtement prendrait cette spar est
tellement suicidaire
tour d un ya peut-être faire tousser 6
pourquoi pas il veut provoquer la prise
sur bembe 6,6 au quai des cinq amis à
peut-être dames 6 hay adams is assez
chiant saddam eu six ou sept îles a raté
c'est sûr il a raté l'idée dame si c'est
sûr mais ça doit ni qui ça se voit à la
caméra il content là il a vu le drame si
c'est sûr du brut pour ça qu'il fait
tout racheté 8 comme ça sur damas ici
fait roi ait fuité il a passé la tour du
roy ou 8 peut-être pour pas se mettre
dans du cavalier aussi ces chèques ale
et de était possible un 3,8 le problème
c'est que ça mettait dans un clouage qui
reprend de quoi mais peut pas reprendre
de la dame madame princesse ici doit
reprendre du cavale roi f1 j'ai fait 3e
deux lycées 5 d'accord ils attaquent la
dame sait bien jouer mais c'est très
très chaud là la position
c'est très très chaud puisque tu as des
pièces qui joue pas des deux côtés est
allé roi qui sont bizarres tâte je sais
pas tu as tout qui est bizarre dans
cette position c'est que tactique droit
qui parent et maintenant on fait quoi
bref cette il défend le pion mais c'est
vrai que les blancs ont du mal à faire
rentrer une pièce en jeu d'un f4 j'aime
bien mais il va faire dame prend ses 3
il va vous voyez la dame en âge 6 je
pense que c'est ça l'idée mais ce qui
fait s'il veut essayer de prendre ses
deux pions envoyé h je pense
ok c'est chaud il n'a pas repris en c4
qui pouvaient est comme ça sur qui a
détruit les tours prend il a
complètement changé son fusil d'épaulé
la dame qui vient à eux quatre ils
attaquent g2 qui a aidé trois cavalières
à kf5 la carélie prend du coup y
poussent
ouais là les ailes et elle est où cette
partie la dame que trois secondes un pur
smirnov haye fait contre f4 prise prise
tour f1 qui sort maintenant qui est des
deux qui menace le pion c4
5 pour protéger tourbe et un touret
fuite c'est chaud la tour qui veut
rentrer en f2 peu de têtes where is f de
gf
voilà c'est le bordel de partout les
gars tour à deux je pense j'ai trois y
défend mais il va perdre son lyon tu
ailles mena il menace ma taille menace
pas mat mais surtour f3 ya tout un match
du coup il faut faire cavalier g6 à la
cc c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
tout re un nom il prend là bas il veut
tourner un math à il voulait tour est un
match qu est-ce que c'est bien joué et
qui a rédigé six cavaliers h4 son idée
de fouine s'étaient tour et un math et
quand ça douaniers l'a vu c'était
c'était trop tard ouais c'était c'était
mignon ce qu'il a fait partie qui était
très incertaine
pour emad de marloux cavaliers h4 on
voyait pas où il voulait en venir avec
ses coups de cavaliers en fait il
voulait en faire mes droits
il n'a pas voulu dame est en fait il
voulait en faire mais le roi il matait
c'était très bien vu de la part de
smirnoff qui reprend les quatre points
d'avance comme disait un but que le
match est quand même assez incertain à
mon avis devrait essayer de viser s'il
peut le faire de continuer à faire
l'écart à monter à 5 6 points d'avance
basse adouani je le trouve nerveux ouais
il est un peu nerveux mais c'est un peu
l'attitude que moi quand j'ai cette
attitude c'est quand je sens que je suis
pas en grande forme et ça ça me rend
nerveux en fait ses parents une question
de concentration c'est une question de
forme
tu sens qu'il ya des choses qui
t'échappe était nerveux
maintenant spin off qui a bien un qui a
bien joué
à l'énergie 1 il y aller il a tout donné
c'est un adversaire qui dans dansez
dansez anti berlinoise ils seraient plus
des a plutôt bien géré jusqu'à
maintenant ça douaniers ya peut-être pas
un niveau objectif énorme et certaine ce
camp se ressemblent bien la défense des
finales ordurières où les plans de maths
originaux ouais c'est vrai 6 broches
c'est pas faux
après il ya aussi des gros trucs de
merde genre là surtout il ya grand roque
est hyper déjà le food et 4 c'est quand
même un niveau de jeu qu'on attend pas
sur un match retransmis pendant 3h30
quoi il va peut-être s'en sortir mais
[Musique]
oui ok puis on prend bicici acquis et
des cistes l'autre à la rater mais on
est encore floue prend 1 f1 dame prend
f1 il ya quand même des sacrée mauvaise
séquence aussi un bon rien n'est calculé
ça joue un peu au petit bonheur la
chance
il ya quand même beaucoup de mauvaises
séquences mais là du coup peu d'âme à
vii c'était très mal joué en fait
peut-être la mettre en fuite scène dame
qui leur a fait pousser trois fours en
f1 mais ce n'était pas du tout anticipé
quoi j'ai l'impression après d'un rêve 7
a vraiment été mal joué
parce que perdre ce pion c'est grave
même si tu as la qualité de plus en fait
maintenant tout est pions sont faibles
c'était ton pion de liaison en fait
qu'il y ait les les pions et du coup
même après calais g7 prise g7 et dames
c4 peut-être ça marche mais ça a l'air
de marcher il se laisse prendre à f/5
qui va reprendre 2 e
ouais c'est pas mal ce que sur grand
kiel à damas six c'est pas mal joué et
là il va mettre la tour en images in ou
dame assise soit dame assise sans fautes
directes plus fort damas six et
maintenant on prend f5
je pense pas que tu veilles dames c6
d'amd cet échange et les dames parce que
plus on prend d'amener cette tour à tour
un tour cet oued ailleurs il fait ça
comme ça et là il va faire tout re 1
tour 7 le roi va devoir aller en g8 et
il va falloir trouver un bon coup dame
prend à 5 bien joué aussi
alors il peut prendre ses 7 passes que
sur dame c'est 5 à tour un roi et fuite
d'am dam des 8 et maintenant il va
envoyer yvan colonna dames 5 c'est plus
ou moins seul coup il va prendre ans et
si j'imagine sur echez ou alors il prend
1,5 et ils jouent la finale
damien meyer dame prend un échec non
mais c'est terrible non mais c'est
terrible ce genre de faute et dames 5
dans le français s'incline mais c'est
terrible trop d'erreurs comme ça dans ce
match c'est ridicule perdre la tournée
on est ce assez
c'est un peu ça tout le match mais ça ça
fait un peu mal au coeur de regarder ça
pendant des heures erreur de fatigue
erreur de fatigue de smirnoff
c'est je sais je me retrouve dans sa
situation quand je suis à 6 heures de
stream en fait eu à peu près dans la
forme de smirnoff maintenant et je fais
des gaffes comme ça mais
non je sais pas ça m'agace quand je
regarde les compétitions de voir ça en
fait parce que tu vois qu'il ya un
joueur qui est quand même largement
avantagés par rapport à l'autre du coup
je suis vraiment pour smirnov ce qu'il a
il est quand même clairement très très
très désavantagé par l'horaire donc je
suis pour le joueur australien
mais oui il fait il fait ce qu'il peut
hein
c'est dommage de ne pas être un peu plus
en gestion du coup certaines fois ne pas
faire d'un pro 5 rentrer dans la finale
il n'y a pas trop de décalage horaire
entre la lord et l'australie oui bah il
aurait fallu faire vu le match à 14h
europe européenne mais problème c'est
que voulait faire jouer tous les matches
à la même heure et donc il fallait que
tous les matchs joués à 18h et donc
c'est mal tombé pour smirnov
mais clairement ça le pénalise
ça pénalise puis c'est pas trop ce qu'on
a envie de voir en terme de spectacle
quoi c'est quand même de la gaffe de la
gaffe qui est plus qu'évitable c'est une
française
enfin c'est passer par une ligne
sicilienne mais c'est une structure
française avec la pression sur le pion
des quatre bien défendus par les
cavaliers là surgit quatre cavaliers h4
c'est très thématiques
il va envoyer f5 et là il ya peut-être
cavaliers prend 2,5 non non mais attends
c'est juste un pion dans quand même les
deux voit pas quand même c'est terrible
c'était annoncé c'est dur en fait il se
tire mutuellement vers le bas ya
énormément de fautes c'est vraiment pas
un beau match
ils sont tous les deux ont éclaté au sol
est traqué mais quand ça dure une heure
ou une heure et demie c'est une chose
mais quatre heures de ça c'est quand
même assez sévères non mais bien sûr
qu'ils avaient trois tons prend ce qui
est prend des cats et une idée tard
walser mais quand même qu'ils aillent
prendre cinq simples on en n'est pas
géré quand la partie d'avant il ya une
tour en 1 il ya un pion en un an b60
bout d'un moment là en l'espace de 2-3
partie on a peut-être eu cinq ou six
grosses gaffes
alors ok
comme je vous dis ça m'arrive d'en faire
aussi etc mais mais bon pour ce niveau
là c'est vraiment beaucoup ces deux
joueurs sont quand même nettement plus
fort que moi j'essaie s'est expliquée
que par la fatigue
d'ailleurs ça me rassure c'est à dire
que si les gens stream est passé autant
de temps à bosser que moi peut-être que
je réussis un peu moins bien ils
feraient des gaffes comme je lé fais
aussi ça me rassure à ce niveau là on va
dire je suis pas mécontent du fait que
ça joue à pas super bien
moi aussi j'en fais beaucoup quand je
suis fatiguée et du coup c'est vraiment
normal mais mais bon là le truc c'est
que c'est pas un des 2 c les deux
vraiment ils sont tirés vers le bas
entre entre eux
et tant mieux qu'il voulait.après il
aurait fallu plus d'heure de match et là
pourquoi il fait pas qu'il prend des
quatre noms mais là il y avait forcément
quelque chose qui l'a gêné un cavalier
f4 d'accord allez peut-être des karellis
et de des trucs mais oui je comprends
oui j'ai plus là et comme je dois jouer
souvent avec après beaucoup d'heures de
stream chat recul patron et après
beaucoup d'heures de travail j'ai
l'habitude de jeu vous différemment en
fait quand je suis fatigué j'ai appris à
gérer
il va vouloir faire bouger 5 c'est quand
même bien joué
le bullet s'arrête la boucherie r ça va
être terrible bull est le bullet va être
terrible
je ferai tour et fluide perso j'aurais
faire jouer cette pièce là un peu mes
tours c'est 2 à l'air très bien réussi
un il tout le truc qui masque et prend
des quatre il se place il joue vite
après il ya un truc de bien qui fait
peut-être smyrna fla peut-être qu'à idée
de ce qu'est ou quatre noms ou au qui a
aidé de quelques 4 ça donne envie d'en
ho là là ou là là haut ce petit cavalier
a eu quatre là il va être monstrueux je
pense qu'il va y aller je pense qu'il va
y aller il va être monstrueux il va être
très beau ce cas rien à 4 va être
monstrueux maintenant il réfléchit qui a
commencé par touré fuite
mais ce cavalier e 4 peut faire très mal
il a pas mis finalement il va pas y
arriver il veut mettre le foin b6
j'imagine
parce qu'ils soient est la tour 1 qui
arrive en effet si si si peut-être un
problème il a fait tour c4 ça a l'air
d'être mieux joué qu'à ses 5
il va prendre ces s'inquiète pas fou
c'est ça oui menace ou prendre 5 sur
échec c'est bien joué et fou prend b2
maintenant au fouet 4 il prend plus le
risque
il ferme la porte est maintenant de 5
des quatre rois des cèdres ça rentre
tout seul
pourquoi pas des 4 5 il fait 5 pions
pouces il va prendre d'ici j'imagine
il va envoyer le valais prendre le pion
là bas ils auraient pu faire roi prend
ses cinq quand même encore une gaffe
mais ça devrait passer
si on va arriver à eux deux
thiaroye g2 et fort ses pions le 2 mai
on va penser cinq petites aux
volontaires ne pas le prendre
il va se prendre un échec
8 fou 3 ha est le problème sexy pouces
d'am-dam échec croise et roya plus
d'échecs way et ça va gagner à les
reprendre quatre points d'avance notre
ami smirnov
il reste combien de temps il reste 2
minutes 30 il reste une partie dans la
cette cadence
merci à dave contre 4 6 ans pour le seul
fait d'avoir ces 3
il va jouer b4 vous avez fait par contre
le pion mais je ne sais pas j'aime son
qu'il avait oublié quand même ce que ça
pouvait donner des tours des six échecs
à certains moments qui aurait pu être
embêtant
là ils gardent le pion plus s'ils
gagnent sept parties gagnent quasiment
le match après 1
ouais smirnov joue bien ça fait motifs
tactique ouais c'est pour ça qu'on voit
que c'est réellement un problème de
fatigue en fait c'est pour ça que c'est
qu'un problème de fatigue parce qu'en
fait sur le placement de pièces on voit
qu'il est quand même bien au dessus
bâle est un pion de plus mais
normalement tu passe jamais cette caste
c4 après je prendrai les blancs un pion
de plus c'est toi qui travaillent mais
problème c'est que voit pas dans quel
monde il va au bout de cette compétition
en jouant aux stars la nuit je vois pas
dans lequel monde il peut aller au bout
la partie basse et renée claude jarry ou
bien il pleuvrait la partie va se
terminer quoi qu'il arrive il est
repassé au dessus des 3000 ray le pire
si je n'en il rejouera contre un indien
mais bon il est quand même beaucoup plus
tôt en inde je crois qu il est 21h là il
doit y aura deux heures et demi d'écart
et clin d' il est 23h30 entre 23h30 et
5h du mat
enfin jouer le match de 20h à minuit
c'est complètement différent que de deux
heures à 6 heures c'est quand même pas
la même
oui faire bref 7,4
je pourrais les phares mais ils m'ont
pas l'art des deux frères
il aurait fallu qu'ils jouent le match
en fait beaucoup plus tôt qu'il joue
genre à midi pour qu'il soit 14 heures
en inde et 20h en australie
faut faire gaffe de ne pas se prendre un
tour à 5 tours prend 1,7 qui peut être
un peu acrobatique mais qui peut quand
même gagner un pion il ya aussi des
tours prend 1,5 puis on prend un f4 pour
essayer de comme tu as déjà un pion tu
peut sacrifier la qualité pour en
prendre un deuxième
qu'est ce qu'il faut il a filé un lion
il a filé un lion ben c'est pas trop
pourquoi tu es le roi j'ai six f4 mais
la france et 3
mais le truc c'est que comme le roi est
venu en f si sûr à fougue et de
découverte
donc ça se goupille bien pour lui parce
que si droit étranger ici sur une foule
prend ces trois avec le roi et si ça
marchait plus ça lui arrive permettent
de récupérer g3 et d'être mieux valait
peut-être qu'ils viennent à angers 6
moi je quatre tours g4 fou prend 1,5 à
lui raté
encore une faute tactique fourrage
après des fois c'est pas si grave mais
c'est à chaque fois c'est s'est pas vu
de base quoi
bon tour h3 le roi blanc peut se
retrouver très faible d'ailleurs il
propose nul avec les blancs mais ok ça
doit être refusée par les noirs n'ont
ils acceptent cfoot accepté ici à -4
dans le match position il peut mettre la
pression sur l'adversaire vient de
gaffer ça très étrange d'accepter la nul
de la part de ça doit ni mais bon c'est
étrange qui est quand même derrière il
doit il doit remonter il a une occasion
de remettre un point étrange
étrange
c'est le 3 mai nom étrange étrange
d'après après dans la position non mais
dans la situation de match oui parce
qu'il y avait quand même le potentiel
avec les foules à tour qui arrive de
peut-être faire quelque chose
c'est excellent et s'il revient à 1 84
point il peut encore faire quelque chose
on va voir ça on va voir ça bon allez je
vous ramener la petite pub on va se
refaire la pause vous repasse la partie
on se retrouve dans cinq petites minutes
les gars a tout de suite
you re bonsoir
ous alors il reste plus qu'une demi
heure de match il reste encore une demi
heure de match m chrono et après on
affinera sur l'autre chaîne pour pour le
cours de fab holding malheureusement il
reste que 30 minutes ouais il ne reste
que 30 minutes mais ça doit livrer ce
sera la fin de ces huitièmes de finale à
fond passera aux quarts moi j'ai enlevé
le coussin a pour le moment je le
remettrais
donc ça va repartir je regarde un rester
là pose encore
j'écris sur messenger en attendant la
reprise je voulais pas rater le début en
fait je pensais que ça reprendra à 21h
c'est vrai qu'il est prêt smirnov qui se
chauffent
donc ça va repartir
moi je suis avec mon chrono ouvert star
de décapage et du chrono ça peut être ça
peut avoir son importance en fait le
chrono si le match devient serré
c'est un bras ses fauteuils non en vrai
c'est pas c'est pas très cher le mien je
crois que les acheter 150 euros à l'efap
ce sera forcément mieux un bal à la ce
match c'est compliqué après moi je m'en
sors pas mal on réussira pas à avoir une
mauvaise audience ont réussi à pas trop
mal commenté j'imagine mais on est quand
même 430 ce qui est pas mal on n'a pas
de premières pages crois que les
espagnols ont une première page sont que
415 tu vois les allemands ils sont 24
les américains il avait une première
page aussi les portugais 248 arx et des
langues où il ya plus de potentiel en
plus de gens qui suivent mais mais en
soi c'est juste que l'on en fait
le rugby c'est pas du tout et surtout à
8 millions après ça que tu as écrit en
parlant de tf1 qui essayent de
s'alimenter
non mais c'est réellement extrêmement
loin c'est extrêmement long quand tu
penses que le match a commencé à 18
heures c'est vraiment c'est fou en fait
quand il pense c'est fou
quand tu y penses c'est vraiment ouf
ben ça reprend pas en plus sur un fil à
+4 normalement il ya neuf parties en
plus un 8 ou 9
donc il faut qu'ils fassent faut qu'il
fasse 2 3 points
c'est ici qu'on va et surtout pour
smirnov qui joue deux nuits 1 et salut
sur la
c'est pas trop ce qu'ils attendent
ouais le cours de fable sera juste après
ouais bon allez c'est parti
tac j'envoie le chrono je vais envoyer
au bon moment nickel
on va le remettre on va voir on va voir
dans ce bull est comment ça se dessine
déjà changement d'ouverture ils jouent
des capi et c3 donc les classements en
bullet ces deux 1975 pour ça doit ni à
2910 pour smirnov et on va voir risqu es
que ça al'avantage finalement de jouer
vite quand quand il est fatigué ou pas
je c'est une question que je me pose
souvent
est-ce que des fois c'est pas même plus
facile en bullet on voit les coûts tempo
mais d'un autre côté tu rates tu rates
comme encore plus de tactique donc dur à
dire en tout cas le début de partie
s'était bien préparée contre ce qu'avait
laissé 3 il démarre plutôt bien avec le
fj enquêtons en bessette et il va
envoyer du c5 il a gardé le foin est
fuite
du coup la dame en g3 elle gêne pas et
j'imagine qu'il va partir pour pour ces
cinq maintenant dame b6 éventuellement
c4 ou des 4 et jouer avec grand roque ma
foi ça m'a l'air d'être pas mal damas un
qui menacent des cats petit rock et
maintenant il va sûrement jouer avec
grand roque way à 4 des quatre qui est
bien et l'autre va jouer pour ces quatre
pour pour ouvrir les dames position qui
en longues ou en partie même blitz
aurait pu paraître vraiment cool pour
les noirs après ça peut être un peu
truqueurs le cas et qui va rebondir vers
un verre f3 des cats a peut être des
systèmes un peu bizarre il bride et si
l'adversaire a l'habitude de les jouer
ça peut ça peut être ça peut être
compliqué là il va prendre le pion à 4
alors ça ça fait super peur l'autre
prend ses 4 alors je vous avoue alors
sur des princes et cathy lecavalier
prend à et sur dame b 5 tours prend 1,4
à huy ah oui voilà ces jolies dames b5
tour prend à 4 mais alors il ya
peut-être un fou des cinq ici qui était
intéressant pour le foot france et 4
alors il a fait roi des huit tours à et
il s'est fait piéger
smirnov et on voit qui réfléchit
beaucoup ils n'y arrivent pas où ils
n'arrivent pas à accélérer
je vois bien une remontée ada de sa
douaniers un perso les gars parce qu'il
est quand même bien plus frais
et cette île va menacer des tours prend
1,6 il ne fait pas encore mais ça va
peut-être arriver dames c'est cet échec
là qui va venir d'un problème si c'est
bien aussi
tourbes et 4 il vient clouer attention
de pas se prendre d'alger de matt s'est
passé pas c'est pas rater tour 17 fou
prend aux cinq tours g8 il essaye de
placer un contre le fu g3 règne en
maître
devant le devant le roi dame ses seins
qui menace tout reprend j'ai trois dames
des cats il lévite tams et 6 il espère
un e 5 à un moment donné mais qui
n'arrive pas peut-être qu'il va tenter à
les rois 8 non maintenant il se fait
déplacer la dame elle est même enfermé
et ça va faire 1 0 pour ça doit ni et
c'est vrai que le scénario est très
inquiétant pour le joueur australien et
l'appui on prend damas is matt
alors clairement ici c'est qu'il est
crevé il essaye de jouer la pendule à
fond clairement il sait qu'il est crevé
et il va il va essayer de faire tourner
la pendule après c'est son arme il a
besoin d'utiliser toutes les toutes les
armes qui sont à sa disposition pour
l'emporter
on peut le comprendre là est-ce qu'il va
y avoir une méthode ruiz méthodes russes
de cavalière en f3 le fou en c4 donc il
reste combien de temps pour voir il
reste 26 minutes la partie a duré un peu
plus de trois minutes
ouais c'est ça il va en avoir 9 10
arrivent à avoir à mon avis il va se
faire il va se faire coiffer sur le
poteau
à mon avis on va voir le retournement de
situation et du coup on aura compris
l'idée de ces formats longs c'est de
[ __ ] quelqu'un par le soir pour le
faire jouer en pleine nuit et le faire
voeu le plus longtemps possible pour
l'épuiser
ce qui permet de voir la résistance au
sommeil des joueurs peut-être tu vas
faire qu'à l'étranger 5 je sens bien
partir là dedans je le sens bien être un
peu trop aventuré et craquer
les chiens en tout cas rester sur alors
après ce qu'il est trop aventureux ou
est ce que ça marche ça c'est une autre
question
mais c'était sûr qu'il avait envie de ça
alors maintenant skf si c'est un coup il
fait faux f6 dame j'ai quatre dames g4
était sympa la frégate est très sympa il
n'est pas fou pranger 5 pouces il y
avait le cavalier e set en l'air dames
g4 était très sympa bon c'est peut-être
reculer pour mieux sauter grand roque
cavaliers des six qui arrivent et à g4
g5 un g6 qui peut arriver là le cavalier
il invitant des six il y va aller tête
dame g4 vous prend 1,4 j'aime bien il
attaque ici four b3 il se replace il
attaque ici il a quoi il a déjà deux
pions pour la pièce il menaçait vii
ouais ça ça a l'air d'être plutôt bien
pour smirnov aller serait bien qu'ils
qu'il la gagne qui reprennent ces quatre
points d'avance fous ces quatre il s'en
prend pas aux trucs pour le moment ma
tension damas cinq menace dames 1 et le
pion b2 il faut peut-être joué un coup
droit roi c'est 2 3 b 1
et oui parce que si la dame arrive mans
et tours prend b2 ça va faire mal il
fait b3 alors là il faut les avoir bien
accroché cavaliers b6 ya le pion ces
trois ans l'herbe et 3 ça vraiment la
tête d'un très mauvais coup rsa va pas
du tout à ce qu'il fait à celui d'un
fils en peut plus il en peut plus mais
ça a l'air encore de tenir fou prend f7
par un tour de passe-passe dame prend
ces trois dames ces deux il va échanger
ans et 2000 assure sa pièce de moi en
vrai il a toujours sa pièce de moi mais
allez il peut encore envoyer les pions
peut-être le fait d'avoir très peu de
temps pour les deux joueurs ça peut le
favoriser ça va plus jouer sur les
réflexes et moins sur la petite vision
tactique et en plus il a le plan facile
là pour envoyer à l'essai partie
cavaliers f7 le roi est très mal placé
il doit aller en g7 allait h6 sur échec
geci sur échec tour gerin sur échec est
fou g5 sûr ça fait pas mal encore et
encore rage et 6 mai fu prend de cet
échec et il ya la tour qui arrive
angers7
ça doit ni qui n'a pas trouvé le gain la
faille et finalement smirnov qui égalise
dans la section de bullet et qui garde
ces quatre points d'avancé 23 minutes 40
encore à jouer samedi sera un peu
injuste qui perdent après justice et le
score après c'est vrai qu'il est très
désavantagé mais ce serait pas injuste
ce serait lié à un désavantage certain
après ça lui de gérer aussi son effort à
les b4y ci après 4 c'était peut-être
game 1 des cas c'est peut-être game
parce que là ça va lui laisser le temps
de faire petit rock
il s'en est rendu compte maintenant
smirnov arrive à faire acheter j'imagine
ans à 4 directement allé là il a
sûrement raté un bep quatre tours à 7
c'est assez naïf il s'en fout c'est 5
avec tempo d'heure il a fait un petit
mouvement de la tête et tours d2 c'est
quand même assez ridicule mais il va
reprendre à question reprendre dois-je
était plus logique puisqu'ils manager 5
en plus mais fou g5 bien joué à faire
froid b8 y couvre dame f4 il ya plus de
fouet cet adam prend f7 ils attaquent
allèles damerey faire que chacun attaque
devant soi parce que regarder toutes les
pièces blanches là sont bloqués de ce
côté là et toutes les pièces soir sont
bloqués de l'autre côté et ça fait un
jeu bizarre où chacun joue devant son
roi plutôt parce que c'est là que que ce
se trouve leur jeu que réside leur jeu
mais le truc surtout cette dame f4 il
réussit pas revenir en jeu alors après
peut-être par damas six dames h7l peut
tenter un truc merrill a filé le pion c4
il n'a pas vu ces terribles fallait
faire fou des cinq avant il a filé le
pion en un alors il a encore cette
enfilade mes tours b 4 tours prend tour
des six et tout reprendre et devra rater
tout reprend des deux nil a pas vu que
c'était un échange
ouais non et non il en il n'en peut plus
il est exténué quoi c'est vraiment fait
il fait vraiment toutes les conneries
que je fais quand je suis claqué
toutes ont proposé un échange tu vois
pas face et il fait toutes les erreurs
de fatigue possible ces sommes
ces perdants après il veut il veut faire
tourner la pendule mais ça vraiment
autant je critique de temps en temps
quand les joueurs le font autant là on
comprend vraiment pourquoi il le fait
autant l'on peut vraiment pas lui en
vouloir
les raisons pour lesquelles il le fait
sont claires et évidentes
ouais
il va finir par se faire mater par le
duo dame fou chantier réside quand même
assez longtemps c'est bien j'ai réussi à
faire jouer beaucoup de coups et à faire
perdre du temps il va récupérer le pion
b500 un adversaire qui est pas exempt de
tout reproche pour convertir une partie
qui aurait pu convertir en quelques
secondes
non mais attends il va pas convertir
iliad 1.4 non mais c'est fou il a dû
rater des matches ou des choses c'est
impressionnant ne pas convertir ça en
fait dans mes pièces et deux pions plus
avec 40 secondes à la pendule avec des
réseaux de maths de partout mais c'est
incroyable de pas convertir ça quand
même
mais là là c'est damev deux échecs non
mais c'est raté ça c'est ok même à 1200
en fait s'est énervé mais je suis sûr
qu'il ya des moyens de materia v10000
moyens de gagner
non ça c'est vraiment impressionnant
raté ça c'est impressionnant
c'est je vous jure ah ben je pense qu'à
huit ans je rate ça je suis je jette jeu
je jette tout par terre quoi c'est
incroyable de rater ça assez c'est très
très violent ça représente une facilité
je peux même pas exprimer à quel point
c'était facile de gagner la rue là c'est
non c'est pas la fat pu tout le match en
fait il est nerveux
smirnov c'est vraiment la fatigue de la
nuit ça doit ni je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ratent des trucs
simples je sais pas pourquoi mais je lui
ai dit moi quand j'allais jouer en pro 2
classique mais paru d'être très faible
n'avait pas battu mais j'étais écoeuré
ne pas l'avoir battu 6 qui est nulle et
ses membres ce qui fait des supers
partie en longues
il est vraiment fort en langue il a fait
des nuls qu'on des grands maîtres et
tous deux types car yakine de top
mondial et c'est quand il a le temps il
est très fort et quand il est quand il
n'a pas trop le temps qu'il a pas trop
les prépas j'ai l'impression qu'il peut
faire des choses incroyables mais là
quand même les gars je pense que la
plupart des gens dans le tchat avec 40
secondes et une seconde à la pendule
quand même la gagne et ça là il a
peut-être raté un matin de way avait un
moment des fous qui revenait enfin
surtout qu'il avait le temps s'il avait
eu 3-4 secondes je dis rien parce que tu
joues tout tempo mais à 40 secondes à la
pendule quand même avec une seconde de
rajouts bon ça ça peut être la partie
qui fait complètement flanché le match
côté à côté smyrna fin normalement et
evra je sais pas je peux toujours la
rate et on peut toujours raté sa mère
mais bon là quand même bien ça
paraissait vraiment quasi impossible à
rater et la sueur g4 se passe quoi parce
qu' à dammaj quatre échecs qui arrive
quand il a pris la pris six mois qu'il
peut faire cavalier
j'ai trois quarts et ligier devrait oui
où ça et on prend 1,6 ouais il craque ça
doit ni il fait n'importe quoi et la
fois abandonnés çà doit ni la faux pas
la jouer celle là ouais ça va être fini
et ça aurait été un très petit match des
deux hommes avec un nombre de gaffes
impressionnant voilà plus sain qui doit
rester là il doit avoir encore cinq
parties quand même mais c'est quasiment
c'est quasiment des balles de match à
chaque fois mais la partie d'avant lui a
fait mal à la tête
voilà c'est à eux deux il ya c4 qui
fasse gaffe 1
il n'y a pas assez 4,6 à [ __ ] ans et 4
ils menacent cavaliers prend des deux
l'idée de mais il peut avoir un problème
sur f7 d'ailleurs il a raté un ânon il
n'a pas raté je pensais qu'eric et
prostate ici mais accueille des deux
sûrement mais peut-être damage 5 il a
peut-être raté ça en tout cas il contre
attaque avec damas 5 c'est encore à
l'air d'être une partie d'une bizarrerie
incroyable alessi smirnov la tiens ça
pourrait lui rapporter gros ou la wii
mais là il prend il va prendre très très
cher c'est encore un massacre j'ai
l'impression que les cavaliers c7 ici
qui est peut-être très très fort avec
tours prend des huit derrière le cavaly
protégé par le fou décide de ne pas
aller prendre la dame mais c'est vrai
qu'elle va pas s'envoler
il a gagné la gagne de toute façon et il
a une date de plus à risque qui va
réussir à conclure avec la dame de plus
le roi mal placé c'est maintenant qu'on
va le savoir façon smirnov
on a compris il fallait qu'il joue un
peu le temps et on lui en train de te
tiendra pas rigueur
même si c'est un peu cher mais
normalement il va se faire mater ça il
va perdre la tour
il a essayé de la jouer le plus
longtemps possible c'est ça aussi qui a
fait tilt et son adversaire un tout à
l'heure et là il va attendre suroît
katia dame français 4 il va cesser
tomber il joue il joue il joue le temps
il a raison et c'est ça aussi qui a
énervé ça doit ni tout à l'heure qu'il a
fait qu'il a fait déjouer
il y aurait 13 minutes mais il va il va
devoir aller prendre un point quelque
part parce que quatre points c'est pas
assez
il va devoir allant gagner une il peut
gagner quatre fois c'est possible mais
surtout il fait déjouer son adversaire
il a plus tout à l'heure il a sauvé une
nulle donc on peut pas lui en vouloir il
a voulu jouer le temps jouait le temps
jouer le temps il a sauvé un demi point
il a raison petit mon nom mais petit
manque de classe 6 3 mais ok on le fait
jouer de deux heures à 6 heures du matin
un gars il fait il fait des fautes que
l'on voit que c'est parce que il mais il
en manque de sommeil de ouf qui ne peut
pas lui reprocher de d'utiliser cette
arme en sa faveur mais il a tout contre
lui la il a juste ou contre lui là il ya
peut-être fois 3 non
ok tu as tout contre toi tu joues pleine
nuit tu machin nanani nanana le match
qui dure des heures
enfin ok il ya un moment donné tu peux
tu peux quand même utiliser un truc en
ta faveur
c'est quand même normal mais là ça veut
dire que s'ils gagnent celle là c'est
game là ils jouent bien fait il est sur
courant atteint alternatives comme
souvent quand on est fatigué d'ailleurs
tu peux jouer quelques bonnes parties
mais juste comme ça des gaffes qui
viennent se placer au milieu tu peux
faire du gros caca de temps en temps non
mais c'est sûr qu'il a raison il reste
quoi il reste onze minutes 4 points
d'écart s'ils gagnent ça sera 10 minutes
way nancy gagne celle là normalement
c'est bon et donc après vous aurez la
master class de fab four est la master
class de fab dans la foulée
dans la foulée les cas leur île et 21h24
cette partie là il fait ses cinq enfants
qui réussissent à avancer ses pions
allez va faire b6 maintenant faut qu'il
fasse gaffe de passes 30 dame projet 3
c'était le piège et la haye adam prend
des deux ça doit ni qui filent une tour
en 1 et alors là mon petit ça doit ni si
tu veux qui tresse la moindre chance il
faut abandonner
c'est encore une gaffe cette fois ci ça
doit animer la position était été
perdante là il ya cinq points d'écart
dix minutes 44 faut vraiment qu'ils
gagnent très rapidement mais c'est vrai
normalement normalement c'est mort
surtout que smirnov l'ajout et la joue à
la pendule
après presse aussi à leurs neuf qui a
accepté de jouer mais juste ça ça donne
envie de le supporter un peu pour
l'effort 1,9 qui a réfléchi
c'est vrai qu'il sait qu'il doit tout
qui doit jouer vite et gagner en jouant
quasiment tempo au moins au moins il
sait ce qu'il a à faire
après la déjà qu'il est il a peut-être
déjà perdu complètement
en revanche la cia la moindre nul elle a
encore une microscopique chance de tout
jouer tempo comme il le fait tous gagnés
après il ya pas un cas de figure où avec
une nulle il y reste
il reste dans le match c'est celle là
c'est sûr mais bon
et file le pion qui ferait n'a pas pris
à leucate s'est vraiment fait j'ai
l'impression qu'ils voient même pas
quand il ya un truc emprise ou quoi il
joue vraiment à l'automatisme ça joue
vraiment à l'automatisme mais ça doit ni
keeway qui peut la gagner vite et
s'offrir le rêve
je crois que tous les matches de la
compétition soit à 18 heures ils ont
juste demandé à smirnov si ça lui
convenait de jouer à cette heure-là y
jouer la nuit en australie il a accepté
un point bas y'a pas ya même pas de
débat à avoir enfin il y avait il ya une
règle dans la compétition il les
connaissait il les a acceptées 1 c'est
pas ça mais juste voilà ça le rend un
peu attendrissant dans le sens on voit
qu'ils galèrent à faire un bon match
mais sinon c'est la règle c'est la règle
il est au courant avant de commencer bon
alors il défend vraiment qu'ils jouent
vite je reste trois secondes
il va tomber c'est terrible c'est super
content retombée quand même il a compris
qu'il fallait qu'il essaye de jouer le
maximum de toute façon c'est dans son
intérêt de faire de faire passer du
temps à l'étranger cet homme prend des
saints qui va bouger droit il va essayer
de se faire mater le plus lentement
possible et il rate et l'autre à rater
damas huit matches et ça leur fait
perdre d'avoir raté dans huit matches
cinq petites secondes ça peut être ça
peut avoir son importance
il reste quoi 7 minutes 18 4 parties ça
qu'il faut qu'il en gagne trois dans le
temps qui lui incombent et qui lui des
combes tac tac tac si une partie dure
deux minutes trente cinq minutes ouais
faut vraiment qu'ils jouent tous tempo
là encore il à l'autre a réussi à smyrna
fa réussi à faire durer
il faut qu'il faut qu'il aille à une
rapidement celle là mais oui les
positions et compliquer la position est
complexe c'est parce qu'en cas d'égalité
un deuxième match on rejoue 7h30 à
franck franck parce que s'il ya eu
égalité
ça veut dire que les joueurs sont
vraiment même niveau et que pour être
bien sûr il faut jouer beaucoup plus
longtemps
donc en gros il faut il faut vraiment
jouer très très longtemps pour vraiment
être bien sûr après ce qui est important
voilà ça doit ni qui réussit pas à jouer
vite qu'ils craquent
voilà la cia 6 mai mal autant la partie
va allègrement dépassé les trois minutes
et s'en sera fini
cet enfant ne sais pas c'est ouais non
mais peut-être sept heures ce n'est pas
assez mais malheureusement c'est la
règle je n'y ferais un freak yfrog il se
trouve que c'est en cas de match nul ça
joue 7h30 et s'il ya encore match nul
après 7h30 on joue trois semaines mais
mais il faut deux matches nuls pour
avoir vraiment pour être vraiment bien
sûr je suis désolé mais la règle est la
règle
la règle est la règle voilà ça doit ni
la koala juste une qualité de moi et une
position foutu
en plus il a plus de temps et ça va en
être la fin de ce match et des espoirs
du joueur indien qui abandonne c'est
terminé les amis cinq points d'écart
cinq minutes à jouer
c'est gagner poursuit en off qui aura
mis ouais voilà qui aura un code pas et
bien dominer c'est dur à dire ailleurs y
aura eu beaucoup de gaffes de part et
d'autre il était plus fort c'est sûr
après il a un peu trop gaffé
mais ça a suffi contre ça doit ni ça
suffira pas contre sarine tout cas bravo
à antonne smirnov mais qui parce qu'ils
passent au prochain tour dans un match
qui restera pas dans les annales c'est
le cas de le dire mais
mais voilà belles belles victoires nous
on va je vais vous mettre la pub ici on
va je vais vous envoyer le raid on va
passer sur la master class de fab
donc j'ai tout de suite faire le petit
switch le match le match est
mathématiquement terminée et donc va se
retrouver tout de suite avec la master
class de femmes je vais faire le switch
et on retrouve pas tout de suite les
gars dans quelques secondes
vous pourrez rester ici je vais déjà
envoyé leur aide je vais déjà écrire
raid et d'excellence et live de l'autre
côté le raid par